e
good morning welcome to Edna I'm opening
the public hearing on House Bill 610 and
Barry good
morning was here yesterday for election
law so kind of weird to be on the other
end of this uh my name is representative
rosb I represent the town of gos aware
in Hillsboro 44 I'm here to introduce
House Bill 610 FN relative to repealing
the office of the consumer Advocate
which isn't really quite a accurate
title because it doesn't really repeal
it it just more folds it into the
department of energy um because I don't
think you're going to find the political
will to outright get rid of it so let's
kind of discuss what's happening so the
OCA uh was invented I think the 80s it
actually predates the department of
energy by quite some time um when the
department of energy was spun out a
couple years ago it basically kind of
created this situation where you had the
Pu the uh OCA and the department of
energy so the office of the consumer
Advocate has about five employees uh uh
the consumer Advocate themselves is
either required to be an attorney or
their assistant is required to be an
attorney um it's mostly staffed by
attorneys versus the department of
energy has about 80 employees um
obviously they both deal in energy
policies the office of the consumer
Advocate is tasked with the name that it
is given it is supposed to advocate for
the consumer the residential rate paay
in particular uh on utilities it's
supposed to go in and push a objective
of lowering rates for the utilities for
the consumers uh it's funded by its own
special tax um it's funded by a tax on
the rate payers uh which is actually
kind of hilarious when you think that
its function is to reduce the rate costs
and it actually by its existence
increases them um it's a it's a small
tax it has about a million dollar a year
budget um so it's not like you know this
would be a life-saving cut to the budget
or anything like that or you know there
would be a massive reduction but I do
think its funding mechanism on its own
is kind of uh thetical to its operation
that it's a Exist by raising TA by
raising the rates um so the reason I
think that this office would be better
suited inside the department of energy
is the Department of energy is a much
larger and more powerful now bureaucracy
um I would like to see the department of
energy overall tasked with the job that
the OCA is currently tasked with I'd
like to see the department of Energy's
focus on lowering the rates of for
residential payers um and it's kind of
like the equivalent of bringing a knife
to a gunfight right you've got a five
person office you've got an 80 person
office why don't we take the objective
for the five person office which I would
assume that everybody in here probably
agrees with on face value lowering
residential R pair and give it to the
larger more powerful bureaucracy by
folding it in um so you'll get some
you'll get some cost cost reductions
that way streamlining things um because
right now the OCA operates that's what's
called an attached agency um so the doe
offers kind of support services to the
OCA so it can function because at five
people it cannot stand on its own um
there's going to be some things that are
brought up that I think should just be
addressed right off the bat the very
first thing that they're going to say uh
proponents of this bill is they're going
to say that the OCA is independent that
it's politically neutral it is
independent is a total falsehood the OCA
is appointed through a political process
the commissioner of Ed of of Ed of
Education the commission of energy is
nominated by the governor and appointed
by the executive Council the OCA
receives a nomination from a politically
appointed board that is then given to
the governor who then nominates to the
executive Council who then confirms the
appointment so they both undergo a
political process so if you had an OCA
it's not a statement about the current
OCA if you had an OCA that was
self-interested and wanted to keep their
job they would do what the governor and
the council wanted because if they're up
for a nomination that's what they're
going to do the exact same thing by the
way that the commissioner of Education
would do the commission I keep saying
education Commissioner of energy would
do um if they were interested in self-
reappointment they're not politically
neutral they go through an inherently
political process so this notion that
they're independent is just a falsehood
it's they're not independent they are
appointed through a political process if
politicians don't like how the OCA is
operating they change they they appoint
the board that nominates him and that's
the end of it it's done so a
self-interested OCA I'm not saying the
current OCA self-interested I'm just
saying a self-interested OCA would
actually respond to political pressures
if they wanted to keep their job so
that's just you can look up how how it
goes that's how it is um this would
create government uh this would create
more efficiency because now right now
when Regulators are or anybody's
bringing a kind of an energy policy
through they they have to go to pu doe
and OCA we can just fold that in and
have one less bureaucracy to deal with
and just deal with doe whose Now new job
uh will be to uh promote the lowering of
residential rate payers um a couple of
other things why I think this is is
useful um
I I think the question I think the
question should be asked um what has the
OCA over its history done to actually
lower rates um I did a pretty deep dive
and I couldn't find anything um right
off the bat uh the number one thing that
I found was it was pretty instrumental
in the New Hampshire saves program so if
you're not familiar with the New
Hampshire saves program it's basically
like a rebate uh that you can get for to
do some energy efficient upgrades um and
then I looked at well how's the New
Hampshire saves program funded it's
funded through a tax on the utilities
which is then passed right back on down
the consumers so the consu so that's not
increasing the benefit for the rate
payers you're just jacking up their
costs to do a program that could lower
the cost for some um so that's picking
winners and losers that's not cool um
the other thing is is today uh I've been
told that some of the utilities are
going to testify why they think the OCA
should stay um so it's
if the OCA is supposed to be advocating
for lower rates it's inherently put into
an adversarial position with the utility
companies right utility companies are
inherently going to be profit motivated
there's nothing wrong with being profit
motivated by the way there's nothing
wrong with that but their job is to make
money their companies that's what they
do so if the utilities which are profit
motivated which they make more money
when rates go up is here to say let's
keep the
OCA you should ask yourself the question
why are they doing that um and I I think
that's a pretty I think it's a pretty
damning assertation of you're you're
here to say that the person that's
supposed to fight you should stay that
would imply that they're either not
doing a great job of it and they're okay
if that office stays because maybe it
doesn't have enough
bite um or they don't think that the OCA
is effective and you know a weak
consumer Advocate is would be more
preoccupied with things like regulatory
policies than lowering consumer rates
and we've seen a lot of that so we've
seen the current OCA uh testified in
favor of changing the building codes
from I believe the 2018 standard to the
2021 standard I may have the dates wrong
but the OCA testified in favor of that
so current OCA so some interesting facts
about that that would add about $331,000
to the cost of a mortgage um which
equates to about $
21159 a month based at a 7% interest
rate it would take you 48 years to
recoup that money as a residential rate
payer from your mortgage uh and that was
based that 48e statistic is actually
based on a 4% mortgage so it's probably
closer to like 56 to 60 years before you
would ever see that money back so when
you have an office that's kind of taken
its quote Independence and is maybe
veing into the realm of unaccountable
you would see them do things like that
like they've done where they've
advocated for policies that are actually
hurting the residents maybe not the
residential rate payer but the residents
of the state um and I think that that
should be addressed by this body uh when
people come up to defend it um which
they understandably will so kind of
bringing it all um back I'm just going
through my notes here because I have a
lot of notes here um oh uh one other
thing that's going to get brought up I'm
glad I wrote it down um somebody is is
going to say the doe Department of
energy just does what the governor wants
I want to bring you back to how the OCA
is appointed the OCA is appointed by the
governor so if you Levy that accusation
you also have to Levy that accusation at
the OCA and the OCA can deny that um and
maybe the current OCA doesn't but this
isn't about the current OCA this is
about the OCA office in general you may
get an OCA in the future that just does
what the governor wants because if they
want to be reappointed what's the
easiest way to do it keep the governor
happy um because that's how you get
reappointed um but by taking the charge
of the OCA and giving it statutorily to
the doe you actually restrain the doe um
a little bit and you focus it in to
advocate for the residential rapay um
which I would hope everyone would agree
should be the objective of the doe it
shouldn't actually just be a mouthpiece
for the governor as they're about to
tell you that's what it is I think the
doe should be focused on lowering rates
and there's things that are lower to
rates that as a conservative I don't
like and there's things to lower rates
as a conservative that I do like um I
think that the current policies of the
OCA seem very focused on efficiency um
and not focused on energy Generation Um
the an easy example is our current OCA
was endorsed by a group called no gas no
coal now I'm not trying to make a
statement about climate change actually
happened to be one of the Republicans
who believes in climate change um I
believe in carbon's emissions and and
that sort of things and how it does have
an effect on the earth um however I also
happen to be pretty well versed in how
ISO New England extension New Hampshire
gets its energy generation it's mostly
through natural gas uh natural gas
creates what's called great Baseline
energy Baseline energy um base load
energy is basically the energy that's
always available right so wind and solar
are not always available um if the if
the wind's not blowing or the sun's not
shining there's no generation that's not
basow generation natural gas nuclear are
our two main sources of Base load
generation we saw what happened to
residential Rays when the war in Ukraine
started and all of a sudden the Russian
natural gas market was disrupted right
the rat shot through the roof so we know
we know we know that when natural gas is
disrupted in New Hampshire that the
residential rates go up it's it's an
indisputable fact because it happened so
why is our current OCA endorsed by a
group
called no gas no coal whose Express
purpose is to get rid of
gas he's they're endorsed by a group
who's that group who exists for two
reasons to ban gas and to ban coal
looked at our current OCA and said great
job we like that we're endorsing
that I would venture to you that maybe
this office has kind of gotten out of
its Lane maybe it's no longer serving
its purpose and I want to get it back to
its original purpose and I think it will
be far more effective if it's rolled
into the department of energy with that
questions representative ree thank you
chair uh Madam chairwoman um
representative Barry thank you so much
uh you cited a couple a figure
$31,000 um to would be added to the cost
of a mortgage um regardless of how long
it takes to pay back I'm just curious
where you got that $31,000 because we
had testimony I think earlier this year
where the Builders Association said
$222,000 per house and then we had
somebody else saying it was on the on
the order of magnitude of 2,000 to 3,000
so could you share that yeah so I pulled
it uh this actually actually pulled this
morning from the national Builders
Association uh they had a they had a
white paper out about it and um it
actually broke it down the majority of
that cost was actually in sheetrock um
it actually broke it down by cost so um
I felt when they were breaking down the
price increases that it was probably
just not a number that they made up and
I'm happy to send it to the committee
thank you thank you
so I would like to I have a question
about the intent of the bill you're
moving the scope of the current Office
of Consumer
Advocate essentially unchanged to the
Department of energy do I understand
that correctly or am I mistaken that is
my intention uh this is one of those
bills that uh OS I was given one redraft
and not a lot of opportunities to change
it um but that is that was my my initial
instructions was remove the Office and
then in my fact finding I said actually
it may not be wise to just eliminate it
um because it is serving a function the
actual intention of it is good um so in
my fact finding of in my fact finding of
should we remove this I went actually no
we should actually just fold it in it'll
be more effective um so I don't want to
entirely eliminate the responsibilities
I just think that the much larger more
powerful bureaucracy of doe should be
tasked with this and this office of five
people should be folded into it um
because when I was doing the process my
kind of fact finding and I discovered
how the OCA was nominated and
confirmed I quickly realized that's a
political
nomination there's a political
nomination here there's a political
nomination here these are both political
nominations so the assertation that it's
independent is just inherently false and
if you're going to have two political
bodies you might as well have the big
one be focused on the people so you can
get you can fold the little one into the
big one make the big one now focused on
the people and I think it'll be far more
effective and you may actually see some
rates go down okay and if I read it
correctly there are still the consumer
Advocate the assistant consumer Advocate
and the secretary that are specified as
necessary staff and then outside
Consultants so
so so it appears that you're expecting
the department of energy to U make it a
three-person office rather than a five
person office correct yeah so you get
rid of two positions um and you'll
you'll also make it easier on businesses
who now have to instead of having to go
to three agency or they have to go to
way more than three to be fair but um
they you're just reducing one less
agency that they have to go to and
you're reassigning that focus and
function to the larger bureaucracy thank
you other representative
grota hi so you say sorry thank you um
you say that the rates may go down yeah
so but they may
not it's it's I would I would contend
you could make that argument now and I
would actually say they're not going
down
now an easy question to ask is what have
they done to lower rates no no I'm
asking excuse me followup followup you
say that by eliminating this the P the
the the uh fee or whatever you want to
call it that's being added to the
electrical rates now
would be eliminated that would be
eliminated but I'm I'm going tell you
the the a million dollars distributed
over a monthly bill over every
residential rate payer that you're not
going to see a a massive change just by
limiting the office um because it's a
million dollars distributed over every
residential rate payer every bill every
month right um so to make that argument
would be very disingenuous but I point
that out because the existence of the
office is inherently antithetical when
it's funded by a tax on the R pairs
which by the way I would point out you
don't get to opt out of right um so when
the independent OCA takes a position you
are funding that through Force um which
is by the way as a person who's followed
me politically you know that I hate
forced speech doesn't matter who's doing
it um and you are effectively saying
that you must agree with the the a
residential Ray must agree with that
position because you're taking their
money by
force um thank you gr so you're thinking
that in 80 e person agency that
basically approves the increases of
electrical rates because that's what
they do is going to have a they do right
when when rise when somebody wants it
increase they have to go to the Pu and
justify it y but this is going to doe
not
pu I'm not putting the same organization
they're not the same organization sorry
I misunderstood that but please don't
don't don't Badger the the testifier
thank you for taking my question so uh
representative Barry do you believe that
uh energy rates would be lowered if
demand is lower I'm sorry do you believe
that energy rates would be lower if
demand is lowered of course they would
but not in exchange for a $211 increase
to your rent and mortgage followup
please
um we're not here to argue with the
testifiers yes
followup so uh New Hampshire saves uh
which you mentioned helps families uh
make their households more energy
efficient icient um so uh do you believe
that enough if enough households were
part of that program that that would
decrease uh energy demand possibly
however New Hampshire saves is funded by
taxing every single residential rayer so
you're basically saying if you don't
participate in it you just pay more I
have nothing against New Hampshire saves
in fact quite honestly I've looked into
using it um because I'm a big fan of
heat pumps once again Republican who
believes in climate
change the OCA should be focused in my
opinion should be focused more on
generation because that is actually
Supply is actually the issue lowering
Demand on energy is very hard it's not
to me that you ignore it but the fact
that we have an OCA willing to tack on
$211 59 to a mortgage it takes 48 years
on the low end to get back says that
maybe the focus isn't in the right place
maybe they're too focused on there's a
term that they use all the time it's
like a societal benefit um and they
basically use that as a justification to
ignore what you need to do which is get
generation going um and I'll give you an
example of things that you could
advocate for that would lower the the
rate of residential rap pairs in the
next two to three years you could sign a
letter to the uh uh to Congress or to
the president saying please allow FK to
build a natural gas pipeline through New
York which has banned natural gas
pipelines entirely which if you
understand geography in order to get to
New England you got to go through New
York right or you could advocate for C
Brook getting its defunct second pad up
and running because
the second largest and sometimes largest
Bas load generator in New Hampshire for
ISO New England is nuclear nuclear is a
clean energy by the way um but we don't
see those sort of behaviors we see a
focus on efficiency which has underlying
issues regarding a an ideology um and
not a focus on building new generation
that new generation by the way that can
be wind that can be solar that can be
nuclear that can be gas that can be
whatever it is but if the charge is to
lower rates there seems to be very
little focus on Supply and a whole lot
of focus on efficiency which has
ideological undertones thank you thank
you other
questions all right thank you
representative representative
sellers thank you madam chair uh
representative Barry so by this bill
you're saying here technically there's
we're going to we're going from five to
three people so automatically there's
two savings at that point if I
understand correctly and I I'm sure sure
there would be a space savings as well
so this would be passed on to the people
is that correct yeah and and you would
and once again I don't want to be
disingenuous with the argument there's
not going to be a massive reduction in
in your bill by folding this office into
the other I'm actually more interested
in giving
doe the Mandate that the OCA currently
has because it's a bigger stronger
bureaucracy it's a lot easier to push
around a five person agency where if one
person quits retires you lose 20% of
your Workforce right than it is to push
around an 80% bureaucracy and it also
gets that 80% bureaucracy regardless of
who the governor is focused on what I
would imagine everybody in this room is
would agree on a bipartisan basis that
thing um thank you madam chair and thank
you representative um so am I
understanding correctly that this bill
would make the mission statement of the
Department of energy um include lowering
residential rate payers um cost that's
my goal of it um it would uh the OCA
does have a case load too that it has to
handle um so they would take over that
case load and that language about case
loading is specifically in here um
because there are concerns that a single
rate payer cannot you know Joe Joe Schmo
cannot go to two hearings a week um
can't advocate for themselves can't
fight the utilities I think that's you
know I have an issue with that on on a
philosophical level of of going into
government but if we're going to say
that that should exist which is what the
current stance of the legislation I
would just give that to the bigger more
powerful bureaucracy if we're going to
say that it should be doing these things
let's give it the bigger weapon to go do
it follow follow up so followup so then
the mission would be to go to these
hearings and fight for the little guy
and make the mission statement of the
Department of energy to lower all of our
constituents prop U Energy prices
correct that would be that would be my
goal of it yes thank you okay
representative Pearson thank you madam
chair
but is the concept here with the
movement of
folks um to put the three positions over
to the doe but not provide the funding
to pay for those positions in essence
making the doe absorb the cost of the
three positions yeah they they would
have to I mean the you know you can you
can go about it but yes it would fold it
in um I don't believe you should be
taxing even though it's a small tax I
don't believe you should be taxing
residential rate payers for somebody
that they can't Advocate that they don't
get to change out so I'm gu the fiscal
note indicates there's a million doll
decrease in Revenue assessment
and more or less a million dollar
decrease in spending
yeah so the short answer is yes holds it
in they are going to absorb the cost of
the three okay you eliminating a tax
would be another way to look at it got
yes we have the Department of energy
here they will be at the last person to
testify so they can answer
questions excuse me any other
questions okay thank you very much I
enjoy it I'll be uh if you need me I'll
be in that room working so thank you
representative
Thomas thank you madam chair and members
of the committee for for the record I am
representative Wendy Thomas and I
represent the town of marac uh there are
going to be several people behind me who
are going to talk about the actual
duties of the uh consumer Advocate I sit
on science technology and
energy and it is incumbent upon our
government to have someone on our side
our side being the rate payers who is
fair and impartial I don't necessarily
agree with everything the consumer
Advocate says but I certainly listen
because he knows how to push back he is
in our
Corner um what I would like to bring
your attention to is on the first page
of the fiscal note the second paragraph
starts with line one the consumer
Advocate is appointed by the governor
and the executive Council for a 4-year
term if the office is repealed the
incumbent would be entitled to payment
of salary and benefits through the end
of the
term this bill is one of the most
fiscally irresponsible things that you
can do good luck explaining to your
constituents that you are going to
eliminate a position of someone who has
and continues to have our rate payers
back pay that person for the next three
years representative Thomas the position
is not eliminated it is relocated if
you'll see on the bill on page three the
consumer Advocate on line 7 is appointed
as part of the department and the and
there are the staff positions are
further down that paragraph the position
is being relocated rather than
eliminated is that not correct
I that was not my understanding my
understanding is that the position would
that no
right assuming the department of energy
appoints the
existing uh com consumer Advocate
assistant consumer Advocate and and
secretary those positions are
established in the department of energy
and will be funded by the department of
energy it is not my understanding that
it is simply moving the position over it
is it is getting rid of the current
consumer Advocate and then rolling in a
new person I believe that's that's not
what the bill specifically says although
it's is a possibility from what the
sponsor said that's not his intent so if
you're you're concerned that the
individuals currently in the position
are doing a good job and ought to be
retained
that's would not be violated by this
bill
necessarily that is not my understanding
but I I hear what you're saying
um how can so if this happened it would
be fiscally
irresponsible um um and again I just
attended the deliberative session in
marac last night and people are paying
attention to costs um I would
just caution if and I guess the the bill
needs more clarification um because that
is not my understanding of the bill um
but I will let the people behind me
speak um and and just to because it was
raised by the prime sponsor um and I'm
glad that the point was was brought up
um bringing the energy codes from 2018
to 21 the rates that the uh Prime
sponsor presented are greatly
exaggerated um and that's my bill we
have we we have that bill with a
separate issue yeah that's my bill and I
presented it here so um um and there
there was a question of why the OCA
would be in favor of that bill and that
is because the bill favors Energy
Efficiency for the rate payers and
that's his job thank you there's a
question representative Schmidt thank
you madam chair so I I agree that the
setup of the bill is confusing it says
repealing the consumer Advocate uh but
as the sponsor explained it that's not
his real intent but the the office of
legislative Services kind of dealt in a
short hand
um so in any case but his argument is it
would be better under the uh doe than
under the governor in terms of
appointment uh and can you speak to the
idea of whether that actually in your
opinion might be the case that it would
be a better arrangement I I would
dispute that but I I'm interested in
your opinion I I will dispute it as well
because the uh Commissioners for the doe
are politically appointed so you're just
taking one political appointment and
appointment representative nearly
everyone in the go in the state
government is politically appointed
except for us poor suckers
representative
Howard thank you for uh taking my
question um so do you believe that
energy producers have an incentive to
increase uh energy consumption in
households to increase yes no thank you
thank you other other questions thank
you very much representative Thomas wait
a minute so you're saying I'm sorry do
you want you you called it Madam chair
do you want me to continue with that I I
you you answered I think that's okay
that's right okay we've got we've got a
whole bunch of people that want to speak
good morning Madame chair colleagues for
the record representative Michael
Bose I represent Rockingham District 5
the town of eeping I chair the science
technology and energy
committee and I'm here this morning to
testify on this bill as being neutral
I'm neutral on the bill but I thought it
might be interesting to talk about some
of the questions that seem pretty
obvious by the filing of this bill for
example we have a Public Utilities
Commission whose job it is to determine
if utility rates are just and reasonable
for all classes of
customers that would include residential
customers so it's an interesting
question to wonder well why do we need a
second check on utility rates in the
person of the consumer advocate's
office well one of the answers to that
one of the possible answers to that
question goes back about 25
years is it turns out
80% of the customers of electricity in
our state are residential
customers but they only buy 40% of the
the electricity that gets
used the other 20% of customers are
commercial so-called commercial and
Industrial
users they buy 60% of the
electricity so you can see that there's
kind of an imbalance between those
classes and 25 years ago people thought
that maybe we needed more protection for
residential rate payers and so the
office of the well first the um
residential rate payers Advisory Board
was created and then eventually the
advocate so that's probably why we're in
the place we're at today where we have
rates I think res representative Barry
he went on for a long time so I'm not
sure if he covered this or not but there
are a couple of things that could
uh improve potentially the office of the
consumer advocate for example right now
St statutory requirement is that the
consumer Advocate him or herself be an
attorney but I think that could be
changed and as long as there is an
attorney in that
office that would allow the office to do
the due diligence work it needs to do in
utility rate cases but if the consumer
Advocate himself was not an
attorney possibly an engineer could do
attorney and another thing to consider
is
that if there is a concern about whether
or not the consumer Advocate is doing
the job that he's charged to do he or
she is charged to do by stat
it could always tighten those statutory
requirements and for example require
that the consumer Advocates office
only act upon
residential utility rate
cases and not other matters uh that
might come before various committees in
the house so that's all I wanted to say
this morning um I know you've got a lot
going on I'd be happy to take
questions thank you representative are
there any
questions don't see any very thank you
Harrington good morning members I'm
representative Mike Harrington I
represent stord 18 the way of background
I've been involved in the um energy in
the Public Utilities Commission uh for
the last 20 years either as in my five
five terms uh and science technology and
energy and 10 years at the Pu some of
which I was a commissioner so just to
give you a little background I think
I've probably been involved dealing with
the office of OCA more than anybody in
this room with the I don't see really
any exception so I have a history with
dealing with this office U first off I
have to say that the sponsor of the bill
U I'll just say is confused he has a lot
of wrong facts statements like more
money when rates go up that is totally
false the utilities pass through rates
if the rate goes up 5% they pass that
through the rate goes down 5% they pass
that through it doesn't affect their
profits one way or the other so
obviously he doesn't really understand
how utilities work he also talks about
the fun of the uh Office of the consumer
Advocate being a tax on the individ with
the rate payers well it's a fee that's
charged it's an assessment that's
charged to the utilities based on the
size of the utility and that's also done
to fund the Public Utilities Commission
so I mean the alternate with from that
would be rather than have the people
that are benefiting if you will from
having a pu and an Office of Consumer
Advocate pay for that it would have to
be simply a tax that everybody in the
state pays because you'd have to fund it
one way or the other unless you going to
get rid of it and have no Public
Utilities Commission so and of course as
stated by the chairman every uh appointy
is political to bring that argument up
that they're going to be less political
when they get to the dees is is simply
silly so just enough of that let me go
on with the things about the bill a few
things there another major thing that
was incorrect in the previous statements
is what the function of the OCA is over
and over again it was stated the
function is to lower rates for
residential rate payers that is not the
function of the office and I will read
it to you it don't go into a lot of
details it says in which the interest of
residential utility customers are
involved and to represent the interest
of util such residential utility
customers represent their interest not
necessarily just to lower rates their
interest could be for example making
sure there's reliable supply of
electricity because I think as everybody
knows people are willing to spend almost
anything during a power outage to get
their well to work and to turn on their
stove so it's more than just lowering
rates that's that's not the only
function of the OCA is to represent the
residential utility customer so why is
this important well again in my many
years of experience at the Pu and at the
science technology any commission we've
had numerous times when people come in
to give a opinion or promote a
particular position these are lobbyists
I mean the utilities have lobbyists
they're backed up by teams of engine
engineers and lawyers there's lobbyists
for all sorts of other organizations the
Bia the business industry Association
comes in their lobbyist the Timberline
associate the Timberland Association
Owners Association comes in and lobbies
uh the um yes we get the point okay so
there there's there's tons of them
environmental agencies and so forth but
nobody comes in specifically to lobby
for the residential rate payer other
than the OCA and that's why it's so
important that this position be kept
independent because if they rolled into
to the Department of energy then they're
going to be basically implementing the
policies of the Department of energy
which may not be singularly in the best
interest of the residential rate payer
it may be they may look at the big
picture and say well for the overall
State it's best we do this but all those
other lobbyists are going to be there
saying well no no no you need to change
it because it'll be better for my
organization or my group or my special
interest group but no one will be making
that argument for the uh residential
rate payer because they'll be told not
to because they're going to be
subordinates of the higher ups in the
department of energy so that is the um
that that is the main reason to keep
this independent and I I believe this is
a solution in search of a problem uh
I've been involved like I say with the
OCA for many years many different ocas
and I've agreed with some disagreed with
others but I think as chairman Vos just
said if you think there's an issue with
how they are are doing their Duty which
is again to represent the interest of
the retail rate payers not necessarily
neily to lower rates then we should
tighten up those requirements on that
and give more guidance to the OCA as to
what to do getting rid of the OCA it's
it's not only silly it's not only
solution in search of a problem it is
really just bad politics because it's
going to make us look like we're taking
this pain in the butt problem who speaks
up a lot and we're hiding them under the
department of uh energy where we can
tell them keep quiet you're not talking
about that issue and I just hopefully
this will found inappropriate to
legislate because it's certainly
inappropriate to legislate and I'll take
any
questions representative
sellers thank you madam chair uh
representative since you've been around
the block a while here in OCA how many
people did they start with and has it
grown I think it's been about the same
overall and and while to get on that
question I should have mentioned also
that the this bill will start right if
it passes it's going to cost over $250
million that we just toss out the window
because the existing OCA as it says in
the fiscal note will continue to get
paid for the length of his term which
ends I think in November of 27 so he can
sit home and watch TV go get a job
someplace else do whatever he wants and
he's going to continue to get paid it's
going to cost a quarter of a million
doar they'll have to pay somebody else
to do that function over in the
department of energy maybe it'll be less
money but you're still losing $250,000
excuse me representative Harrington that
sounds like you're assuming the
department of energy will not under any
circum cumstances appoint the current
consumer Advocate to the position
created in the bill I will let correct I
will let the consumer Advocate speak for
himself but I highly doubt he would take
a position at lower pay to give up
higher pay for not working that I mean
he's pretty logical I would don't think
he's going to take I don't think anyone
would do
that thank you that's a valuable
information representative sellers yeah
thank you uh so wouldn't an option be
just we could amend this bill here to
start at the date this person ends that
will resolve that problem it could be it
would be off in November of 2027 but but
it still doesn't change the my main
problem that's kind of a minor thing
that that the main issue I have with
this bill is it takes away the
independence of the consumer Advocate
who's going to be who's out there
fighting against all the other
independent people who represent the
various special interest groups the
consumer Advocate has a special interest
group it's the retail residential rate
payers nobody specifically represents
them other than the uh consumer Advocate
the dees represents the entire State the
Pu represents the entire
State thank you represent
sles thank you madam chair um I I have a
question in terms of accountability uh
your testimony seems to indicate that
you find the current structure uh
delivers some measure of accountability
to the people of New Hampshire and I'm
wondering if you could express how that
mechanism functions um in your mind and
uh how moving to the Department of
energy would somehow weaken that
accountability sure well as it was
stated by the chairman every office is a
political pointy so it doesn't really
make any difference the accountability I
guess comes with at the end of their
term the governor whoever is Governor at
that time may or may not uh an executive
counsel may or may not appoint them or
reappoint them that's that's where the
accountability comes from just like in
the department of energy the the person
there might be doing what they think is
a great job and then uh there's an
election the governor changes and they
say no you're not going to get
reappointed because we don't like what
you've been doing so I mean it's it's no
different than any other office as far
as accountability goes uh you get
appointed for a specific term and at the
end of the term whoever is making the
decision whether to reappoint you will
decide whether that's a good idea or not
thank you other
questions all right thank you very much
thank you madam chair members of the
committee good to see you all this
morning um I'm here today uh opposed to
the passage of hb610 and I hope you will
ultimately find it inexpedient to
legislate and I'll give you a little
idea why
um it's I think it's difficult for uh
folks who have not had a lot of
experience with the Public Utilities
Commission uh and the office of the
consumer Advocate to understand where to
sort of slot the interactions of those
agencies and how they operate uh there
was a a pipeline project proposed
through New Hampshire in 2014 and that
was the first time I went up to the
Public Utilities Commission to kind of
observe their functioning um and learn a
bit about how that operated here in the
state of New Hampshire I also uh
followed a bill over to the Public
Utilities Commission and was an
intervener so I got kind of an Insider
look as well at providing information to
them um on a docket and so I have a
little bit of familiarity with both of
those things and I have actually known
the current consumer Advocate since
2019 and I'm here to say that I think
that this bill is the result of the fact
that he is a very good consumer
Advocate um and uh what that means is
that his role is unlike any other role
that is played uh in the dockets that
that the office of the consumer advocate
participates in and he understands the
context of that role because he's
qualified for the job by his legal
training he understands the statutory
mandates he understands the interactions
of the parties um to the dockets and he
does an exemplary job of maintaining the
interests of the rate payers in those
dockets and I have seen that firsthand
so I wanted to bring that perspective
here because it's something you wouldn't
have if you never observed how these
processes uh go
on and I'm sorry excuse my voice I'm
have a little bit of a cold um and I
guess another piece of information that
I can bring um that might be um more
information for the committee is that
there's been a little bit of a um Turf
War uh going on with the Public
Utilities Commission and and the office
of the consumer Advocate and others um
and that has to do with political
appointments and how people view their
jobs and that kind of thing too that's
all sort of Insider baseball over there
but it has been in the press as well and
so um I view this bill as um targeted
specifically to remove that ability for
the existing consumer Advocate who I
believe has been been reappointed twice
under Governor sununu's terms um from
remaining in that job because he is
shining a light on the problems that are
happening at the Public Utilities
Commission and I think that that's a
very valuable thing I think my colleague
um representative Harrington kind of
alluded to that beforehand and he has
firsthand experience in working over at
the Public Utilities Commission there's
a role to be played here and it needs to
be independent it um we've already seen
other functions rolled into the
department of energy since it was
reconstituted as part of the Budget
Trailer bill in 2021 when it was
recreated it used to be the office of
energy planning um so there's jockeying
for position there's changes in control
but I think the question comes down to
um what does this bill actually do the I
guess the prime sponsor indicated that
it doesn't necessarily affect this
particular consumer Advocate but line
one says purpose effective after 120
days of the X Passage the office of the
consumer Advocate as created by RSA 363
colon 28 shall be
dissolved okay so it it will be
reconstituted according to them behind
closed doors and not as visible to the
public but it will not be the same
independent agency that we have today
and um so the bill does dissolve the
office as it is constituted today which
is why prior speakers were trying to
explain that statutorily since he is a
lawyer he knows that he is he will be
paid through the end of his term whether
or not he is serving and so what will
what will basically be happening is the
taxpayers or whoever is funding the job
that job and whatever um is
reconstituted within the department of
energy they will be Sim simultaneously
being paid for the same work rather than
um as again represent representative
Harrington alluded to
uh this Pro you know uh solution in
search of a problem uh was brought up to
the legislature so the bill does
dissolve the
role um and that is the first thing that
is the primary purpose of the bill
according to the bill um so I just
wanted you to be clear about that and I
um I think uh what we should be asking
ourselves is whether or not this
consumer advocate is
qualified whether this consumer Advocate
is doing the job that he um is El is
hired to
do and whether whether he actually uh
has
been um standing up in the face of
significant uh push back from utilities
and other stakeholders that he is
regularly collaborating with in order to
come to solutions for the State of New
Hampshire um I have seen him do that I
have been in rooms uh where he has been
working to do that i w i served with
chairman Vose for four years on the
Energy Efficiency and sustainable energy
board which he was a member of for I
don't know that the board
was the board um was in service for
about 15 years and for a significant
portion of that he was on that board as
well so he plays a very unique role and
he is being targeted and that is that is
my perspective on on the bill so if um
you have any questions I I will attempt
to answer them thank you are there any
questions represent
scitech representative McGee you're
talking about this particular individual
we're talking about the Office of
Consumer Advocate would your testimony
be the same if you didn't have this high
regard for the current incumbent that's
a good question and a legitimate
question um I think it would but it it's
it's better for someone to actually know
how the person operat in the job in
order to speak to what the bill would do
right the bill would eliminate this
person who's good at their job from
doing that job um and from being able to
point out uh flaws that are detrimental
to the process uh the processes that
he's involved with right he's
Illuminating things for us that we
wouldn't otherwise know about and I
believe that's why this bill has
happened and I thought that those
insights should be brought here because
often times we have hearings where we're
talking at a surface level about what's
going on on here if it didn't say
dissolve the office if it said we're
going to roll it in then that would be
more of a redistribution of how things
are functioning but that um I don't
think is the purpose of the bill and
it's and it's written in the bill so yes
I do have a high regard um and my
knowledge of how this is operating and
where the bill what the Bill's
motivation is is something I could lend
to the hearing please don't impune their
motivation you can't know what really
motivates people that's that's
true the fact that that's what the bill
says is is fair gain okay thank you
represent that you have a followup can't
wait to meet him yeah yeah I hope you're
as impressed we have fewer questions
we'll get to him sooner representative
reze thank you madam chairwoman thank
you representative MC um quick question
for you uh the how would the um OCA be
compromised and their effectiveness
compromized in your mind by moving it
under the
doe given
perhaps political debates that are no
this is in my opinion um the the board
that I mentioned the easy board I have
some familiarity with um a stakeholder
Group which included the utilities but
it also included weatherization folks
housing folks you know interested
parties that were trying to help the
state of New Hampshire deal with
questions around Energy Efficiency and
sustainable energy so they would do sort
of research and um information gathering
in order to provide information to
decisions cases bills that kind of thing
and we do a lot of I I consider that the
New Hampshire way the the stakeholder
groups um there was a bill last year to
um take the role that the Energy
Efficiency and sustainable energy board
have been playing for 15 years and roll
it into the department of
energy and one of the things that was
good about that stakeholder group was it
was public it was transparent the public
was able to listen into those
conversations
um we don't have that view anymore um
and there isn't as public
um I have no idea what's been
happening in terms of uh those functions
so I think um it's been alluded to by
prior speakers that it's basically the
independence of the office that we're
trying to keep separate from Rolling it
into a division who would then make more
of the decisions and also hire somebody
who maybe wouldn't be
uh as willing to speak truth to power
because it can sometime times be um
embarrassing to have somebody call you
out but um I think the purpose of the
consumer Advocate is to have the
latitude to be able to call out uh when
something
about um Utilities Commission activities
is not uh operating as it should thank
you yep and he's in a unique position to
do it other
questions thank you thank you um I'd
like to take this this moment to tell
the people who are here for cac1 that
we're running significantly
late
and I think that we will have to
postpone you to later today I'm sorry
about this but I've still got a stack of
cards on House Bill 610 that we need to
deal with so
if would it be agreeable to you to to
cac1 3 3 p.m. 3
p.m. yes okay thank you very much I'm
sorry about it but um I didn't believe
House Bill 610 would be quite as
interesting to so many
people okay thank you so
uh representative freeze could you go
out to the door and Mark that the the
3 okay representative
have thank you madam chair good morning
Edna I am Tom Corman I represent Grafton
15 which is Ward three of the
Metropolitan city of Lebanon I am the
deputy ranking member on Science Tech
and energy so I do get to experience the
department of energy the Public
Utilities Commission and the office of
the consumer Advocate frequently you're
going to hear me say something that I
rarely get to say I agree with
everything that representative
Harrington
the Pu hearings uh have the department
of energy and the office of the consumer
Advocate often as parties to the
hearings and I can tell you from what
I've heard in our committee over the
last two plus years that the consumer
Advocate does not always align with the
views of the Department of energy does
not always align with the views of the
does not always align with the views of
the utilities does not always align with
the views of the Republicans on stn and
does not always align with the views of
the Democrats on
st& the OCA is
independent and we need to keep the OCA
independent the OCA literally speaks
truth to power and of course I mean by
power utilities that kind of power but
the other kind of power as
well if the OCA moves into the doe that
removes the independence the OCA as I
said doesn't always agree with the doe
if the OCA moves into the doe You've
Lost That independent voice that we need
at the puc hearings so please don't do
this the other thing to think about in
terms of uh it being a political
appointment the current form of the OCA
is that it's for a four-year term
but if the OCA is moved into a position
in the department of energy it's not a
four-year term appointment that can just
uh that that is independent in other
words if the OCA doesn't agree with the
commissioner of the doe couldn't the doe
commissioner replace the OCA so we need
to keep that position
independent the final thing I want to
if you remove the OCA as an independent
position when you are running for
reelection there are going to be
opponents who point out to your
constituents that you have voted to
remove the one independent voice who's
looking out for their interests as rate
payers now you can try explaining no but
we just moved it on into the department
of energy and at that point your your
constituents are just not hearing it
they're going to hear the one thing you
voted to remove the independent voice
that is looking out for their interests
so just think about that and with that
I'm happy to take questions thank you
are there
uh good morning chair uh chair Maguire
uh honorable members of the committee
especially representative scitec who
said he was excited to meet me I am uh
attorney Donald cree and for the past
nine years and 20 days I've had the
honor of serving as our state's consumer
Advocate responsible for advancing the
interests of New Hampshire's residential
utility customers wherever those
interests arise the office of the
consumer Advocate usually referred to as
the OCA takes no position on House Bill
610 I think it would be presumptuous of
me to attempt to tell the state's
elected officials whether after nearly
50 years our office should continue to
exist as an independent organization
whether it should be folded into another
agency or whether it should be abolished
altogether but I want you to make a
fully informed good decision and that is
what uh prompts my testimony today to
make sure that you have a full and fair
understanding of what we do and why we
do it now using membership in the
National Association of State utility
consumer Advocates as a yard stick we
are one of 43 offices around the country
that work at the state level to
represent rate payer interests the main
stay of the work is participating as an
active party in proceedings before State
utility Regulators in our case the New
Hampshire Public Utilities Commission
the pu's enabling statute and I think
this is really important requires that
agency to serve as the Arbiter between
the interests of utility
shareholders investors who reasonably
enough seek to extract as much profit as
they can and utility customers who want
and need safe and reliable service at
the lowest possible cost with as much
Freedom as they can get to control how
when and why they use their utility
service utilities are well represented
extremely well represented in pu
proceedings it's not unusual for a big
utility like eversource to show up at a
pu hearing with 15 or 20 people lawyers
subject matter experts outside
Consultants we help the Pu do its
Arbiter job by throwing at least a
little bit of weight on the other side
of the
scale the OCA came into existence in
1976 originally as the legislative
utility consumer Council and at various
times we have been an adjunct of the
general court an office within the Pu
and since
1985 we have been a completely
independent instrumentality of state
government if you take one point away
with you from my testimony this morning
and here I have to say that I
respectfully disagree with
representative Barry let it be this the
independence of the office of the
consumer Advocate is our superpower the
energy related policy agendas of the two
major political parties EB and flow
Democrats love to extract special favors
for the solar industry or big wind
Republicans are keen on building nuclear
reactors representative Barry mentioned
that and so-called dispatchable
generation policy makers from both
parties have wanted to rebuild the
economy of the North country by burning
wood to make electricity now I am not
here to criticize any of that my job
however is to point out that however
virtuous those policy imperatives are
they cost rate payers money often too
much money and for the past nine years I
and my staff have made those arguments
at the Pu here at the state house and at
the regional and federal levels as well
a fact in which I take enormous pride is
that I was originally appointed by
Governor Hassen I have twice been
reappointed by Governor cunu neither
Governor has either of those two
Governors has ever attempted to insert
themselves or otherwise influence our
work I know that both Governor Hassen
and Governor sonunu did not always agree
with me but I take their
non-interference as a sign of confidence
and respect for what we contribute to
the process of utility regulation in the
state and region now I I I'm sorry that
representative Barry and and and I want
to say he was kind enough to meet with
me and talk about this bill for an hour
a few weeks ago and I really respect his
willingness to do that and I'm sorry
that I was not able to convince him that
our independence as it is currently
constituted uh makes a difference my
lived experience in nine years and 20
days says otherwise no interference with
what we do he criticized my support of
the New Hampshire saves programs they
are
payer funded uh programs they save
consumers money they survive a rigorous
benefit cost test we assured we argued
for that rigorous benefit cost tests
that's the reason I can confidently come
here today and tell you that those
programs are good for the residential
rid payers that we
represent the question of energy codes
came up that's the same issue right if
you take the energy code and you update
it from the 2018 version to the 2021
version in the long run over the
lifetime of your ownership of a home
built according to the energy code you
will save money now I know that's a
contentious proposition I know there are
arguments back and forth but that's the
reason that I support uh moving forward
with an advanced version of the state
energy codes uh representative Barry
suggested or implied that I am an
opponent of new natural gas pipelines
their other new energy a facilities
during my 9 years and 20 days the OCA
has never not once opposed a natural gas
pipeline or the development of any new
energy facilities that have been
proposed in this state
so uh and I I just want to say I I
listened to his testimony very carefully
and he began by saying that he decided
to draft his bill so that it folds my
office into the department of energy
because he said we lack the uh political
will to just abolish my office outright
well I I think that undermines his
argument again again with
respect here's a couple of other things
I think you should keep in mind a as the
newest cabinet level agency one that is
still finding its wings by the way the
department of energy was created three
and a half years ago to throw some heft
behind the governor's policy agenda when
it comes to energy but as everyone in
this room knows when deciding what to do
about energy and utilities a governor
must consider a pile of competing policy
imperatives what's good for utilities
what's good for economic development
what's good for the environment what's
good for addressing the housing shortage
you name it however those competing
imperatives get worked out they do not
equate with what's good for the rate
payers so governor aot won election in
part by urging us not to become
Massachusetts and look I've tried to
navigate staro drive so I relate but in
this instance the question is really
whether New Hampshire wants to become
Vermont because Vermont does rate payer
advocacy exactly the way House Bill 610
proposes that we do it Vermont has a
Department of Public Service the
functional equivalent of our department
of energy the Department of Public
Service claims to represent rate payer
interests for the Vermont pu but here's
how they do it they simply assume that
whatever their governor likes is what
benefits rate payers and I speak here
from experience as someone who and
please forgive me spent a brief part of
his career as a hearing officer at the
Vermont
pu a related Point unlike New Hampshire
Vermont is simply absent at Nee poool
the super powerful stakeholder body that
deliberates on Market rules and other
matters related to ISO New England The
troublingly unaccountable Entity that
runs the regional electricity grid and I
have been speaking out about that lack
of accountability and I suspect although
you should ask them that that is the
reason that the folks at the no coal no
gas movement have said nice things about
me even though I have never supported
their aggressive climate agenda that
calls for shutting down all the fossil
generation in our region
unlike either the Vermont Department of
Public Service or the New Hampshire
Department of energy we the OCA have the
right to serve as a voting member of
neol and rest assured we participate
actively and vigilantly because neol and
ISO New England are important for the
same reason that Willie Sutton robbed
banks because that is where the money is
here's a concrete example so-called
asset condition transmission projects of
which there are approximately $5 billion
dollar worth somewhere in the planning
and construction pipeline around the
region these are rebuild and expand
projects and here's the problem with
them no regulatory scrutiny I and my
counterparts around New England are
really concerned that at least some of
this spending is unnecessary and
imprudent right now the poster child for
unscrutinized asset condition projects
is ever source's plan to spend more than
$400 million rebuilding its x178
transmission line right here in Western
New Hampshire we are sounding the alarm
about this and I will continue to do
that as long as we are able now rather
than take up this whole hearing which is
already in overtime uh for for myself
I've prepared a handout for you that
covers the basics of the OCA our work
and some of our accomplishments I have
been advised to come in here and try to
convince you that we routinely save raid
paays money in an amount that well
exceeds our annual budget of about 1.1
million do and we do indeed from time to
time get to make that happen but here's
the thing we're really
Cooperators way more often than not
advancing rate payer interests requires
finding common ground with others with
utilities with other agencies with
interest groups and then convincing the
Pu that the consensus that we have built
is what the public interest requires now
I've noticed that no is a very popular
word among my national counterparts but
I would rather the OCA were remembered
for what we built up new technologies
new and better infrastructure new
freedoms that save people money rather
than have the OCA on my watch be
remembered for what we tore down or what
we stopped now Begg your Indulgence I'd
like to end on a personal note at around
the time that New Hampshire was creating
the legislative utility consumers
Council back in the mid 1970s I was a
teenager living in Suburban New York and
my teenage rebellion I'm sure all of you
had one my teenage rebellion took an
unusual form classical music especially
Mozart so one day I read in the paper
that the only all classical music radio
station in New York w n Cen would be
switching at midnight to rock and roll
but when I tuned in at midnight the
announcer gleefully proclaimed that it
wasn't happening because a feisty
citizens group The wncn listeners Guild
had obtained an injunction classical
music on
wncn though briefly interrupted lasted
for another 19 years well my musical
tastes have broadened since then
nowadays I'm just as likely to be
listening to Billy eish or bad bunny as
am to a Mozart Opera but the victory
that I found out about that night in
1974 became and Remains the animating
force of my career it's not about big
government and it's about talking back
to big government and to Big Business by
using people power since 1999 energy and
utilities have been the my focus and
since 2016 I'm proud of what I've been
able to do in marshalling people power
to advance the cause of utility rate
payers really gratified to hear the
leading lights from the house Science
Tech and energy committee from both
caucuses come here and tell you
complimentary things about my record as
consumer Advocate I'm really grateful
and I agree with everything they've said
there is so much more that we can do and
I hope to continue to have the
opportunity to help do it thank you for
considering my testimony thanks in
particular to chair Maguire for the
courtesies that you've extended of
course I'd be happy to answer any
questions that you might be willing to
entertain thank you representative
scitec Mr Cree did you mean
wqxr representative thank you for that
clarification so wqxr back then was the
radio station of the New York Times it
wasn't all classical it was sort of
classical um I have a question in your
current
position who's establishes your budget
and and sets how many people you can
hire
we're currently authorized to have six
people working for us one of our
positions is vacant we grew from five to
six a couple of years ago to do Regional
and federal work and our budget is part
of the state budget so I have to go
before the finance committees first I
have to get the governor to agree so
it's it's the same process that every
other state agency so you are a separate
agent and you have a separate line in
house bill one or one yes thank you
that's that's what I needed to know any
other representative
SL thank you madam chair um I had a
question I I'm I'm curious the the the
bill before us moves your office from an
independent agency into another agency
and the arguments that I'm hearing made
are ones of accountability and so um I'm
trying to to sort out why the current
configuration makes you more accountable
to the people in general um
and what what I'm curious about is when
there is a contentious issue that comes
before your office um what is your
policy your overall view on taking one
position versus the other or maybe not
taking a position at all and when taking
a position how does that represent all
rate payers thank you thank you that's
an excellent question and uh it uh it
means that I get to tell you about
something that hasn't been mentioned so
far in today's hearing and that has to
do with the residential rate payers
Advisory board so The Advisory Board
acts as a buffer between me and the
vicissitudes of the politics of
appointed service in state government
and it meets quarterly and it
deliberates on the very questions that
you're talking about and particularly
over the last uh couple of years since
the speaker appointed the venerable Neil
Kirk who is here in the room to our
Advisory board he has insisted that our
Advisory Board uh have a lively
discussion of the very issues that you
are suggesting that we should be
focusing on so it's not about just
assuming that whatever and my team
subjectively think is good for raid
payers is going to be our position we
those things are vetted at our Advisory
Board and The Advisory Board itself is
nine people three appointed by the
governor three appointed by the speaker
three appointed by the Senate President
so thank you for giving me the
opportunity to make sure you knew about
that I'd like to mention that that The
Honorable Neil Kirk is up next so very
fair if you have a a direct and just
like representative scitech wanted to
meet me I can't wait to hear what
representative Kirk says yes very fair
you have a followup please very narrow
sort of scope to my question is how
would the transition in your view from
an independent agency to the Department
of energy affect everything you just
described well instead of uh answering
to an Advisory Board uh I would report
to the or the consumer Advocate would
report to the commissioner of energy and
again and I'm not here to criticize the
commissioner of energy at all he's an
excellent Public Service servant but you
know he has his conception of what the
right energy policy for the state is and
it's bigger than just what's good for
the rate payers and I would have to just
like my counterpart in Vermont does I
would have to conform what I do to his
or her
agenda okay thank you president um thank
you madam chair and uh thank you my
question is um regarding the New
Hampshire saves um program as somebody
who can afford to make the choices to
save energy as much as I can and who can
rebate shop I know I've definitely
benefited from it but I'm curious how
much you focus the New Hampshire safe
project uh program to make sure that
those marginal consumers the lower
income ones who are barely paying their
electric electricity bill aren't paying
for my larest and other people like me
well the first thing I want to say is
that the NH saves programs are required
to spend at least 20% of their budget on
helping lowincome customers so there are
programs specially targeted to people
who are particularly overly burdened by
their energy and I think your question
was how do I make sure that there isn't
a subsidy happening a sort of reverse
Robin hoodis I think that's the gist of
your question that's a legitimate
question and we keep an eye on that and
that is a a a function of going line by
line through the New Hampshire saves
program offerings and making sure that
they save everybody money uh but you do
raise a legitimate question that is the
subject of pretty intense discussion
when the trienal Energy Efficiency plan
is under
review all right thank
you thank you very much thank
you Mr
Kirk with
introduction good morning Madam
chairwoman and members of the committee
for the record I'm Neil Kirk I live in
wear and I'm a member of the um
residential rate payers Advisory Board
and was appointed by uh twice by uh
speaker Packard to that position and I
am speaking today on necessarily on
behalf of the board but in favor of the
board's position which is it voted to
oppose this bill um and the reason why
I'm here is because this bill will harm
the elderly taxpayers that I represent
I'm not sure whether I should be pleased
with the uh name of venerable um I
remember the venerable a bead as a
book from high school and um he was an
old
guy
um um as you've heard this bill changes
the uh OCA from an independent status to
an arm or unit in
doe and there are consequences to this
that I think you've heard some of but
I'd like to make them in a perhaps a
more pointed fashion first this bill
isn't about smaller government or saving
money the bill requires the
relocated um OCA to do the same job in
the future that it does today the
problem is that instead of having five
or six employees the bill provides for
only three one of whom is a secretary
the problem with that is that if the job
is to be done the same way and the bill
requires the job to be done the same way
uh more money is going to have to be
spent either with permanent employees or
hiring outside experts to give the ca
the new consumer Advocate uh the data
that he needs the information that he
needs to make decisions and carry out
his functions so there's not going to be
any savings Financial Savings in this
bill and as been pointed out uh this all
of these expenses including many of the
expenses of doe are paid for by rate
payers and the we as utility users
electricity water whatever it is pay our
share of these it's a small amount it's
not really relevant as a practical
matter if the doe decides not to fill
those five positions or provide the
necessary expert opinion then it will
have uh emasculated the de the new ca
and he will not be able to do his job as
the statute
requires um hopefully that will not
happen the consequences of not having an
independent um CA are as follows
right now when um we decide our rate
cases there are roughly five groups that
appear before the
Pu um there's the doe who represents the
state's interests whatever they may be
the transmission distributions companies
such as eversource with its 15 folks as
uh this as Mr Cree said um businesses as
consumers of electricity electricity
suppliers such as Direct Energy and all
those list Ed on the Pu website and
consumers through the OCA this bill
takes the OCA out of that reducing the
list to four requiring doe to
compromise what it does it's got to
balance the state's interest as Mr cre
said and the oca's interest to come up
with a single policy the Pu has denied
the voice of an independent
CA and that is not in the interests of
residential rate payers the consumer's
voice in effect is muted it's more
likely that our already high Electric
Residential electric rates will be even
higher than the otherwise would be if
you believe your constituents
electricity rates are already too high
this bill should be
killed thank you madam chairman I'd be
pleased to answer any questions if there
are any all right thank you are there
any represent
SL thank you um one of the previous
speakers mentioned something in regards
to uh rates being set through pass
through or that somehow I interpreted
that as and please feel free to correct
me if I'm wrong that rates are somewhat
fixed or the that the percentages are
somewhat fixed so if the percentages are
fixed how does this office impact rate
payers uh and in the rates they pay uh
through their electricity
bills thank you for the question um
rates are not fixed they are set
periodically by the Pu see usually
because a utility says our costs are
higher we need to pass them on to rate
payers or we've uh invested more and
we're entitled to a higher return on
that investment which rate payers have
to pay so the Pu is constantly having
rate cases and they take as much as a
year to
decide after which these new rates
sometimes lower but almost always higher
are then translated into the rate that
you and I pay and we see on our electric
bill and remember we're only talking
here about
transmission and distribution
electricity rates the the rate you
actually pay for the power is not
regulated by the
Pu it's your choice we have a free
market in that there's the community
power agency that has many towns
offering taking it to Services I
sometimes use Direct Energy right now
I'm on using the default rate ever
Source because it's lower than anything
else why is another question it may be
problematic um but remember that this
case and the OCA is really only talking
about the distribution transmission
rates not the quote power rates the
electricity itself
rate
okay anyone
else
followup yeah if if the Pu is
determining rates how does the office of
OCA lower costs
it
might thank you for that followup um
ever as an example eversource comes in
and says we want to spend $478 million
or whatever the number Mr Cree mentioned
is on um upgrading our um lines putting
in new power new polls and so forth um
even if they're not necessary this is
very good because it's a very high rate
of return mandated I think by the
federal government FK Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission
of
99.65% that they can get on those kinds
of Investments so one of the things that
the OCA would do would be to come in and
say this investment is unnecessary these
polls still have another 20 years of
useful life why are you trying to
replace them now if they're successful
in that argument and this Capital
Improvement does not go forward or
doesn't go forward to the full extent it
otherwise would then rate payers are
saved
The Profit as well as the cost through
depreciation that they otherwise would
have to pay for these rates so the OCA
goes in makes the arguments if the Pu
buys them we avoid a rate
increase I hope that answers the
question follow up this would be rate
increase through their transmission cost
right got it thank you the transmission
distribution cost this probably be
transmission not distribution but would
be a component of their cost has nothing
itself thank you representative Kirk any
other
good morning I have a written testimony
good morning my name is Alan
Linder I'm a h retired New Hampshire
attorney I worked for New Hampshire
legal assistance from 19 1980 through
2014 retired in 2014 but I came back to
work as a volunteer part-time attorney
for legal assistance from 2015 to
2022 before I worked in New Hampshire
representing lowincome and
elderly uh individuals and groups before
the New Hampshire Public Utility
Commission since 1980 during the 7 70s I
worked uh in Pennsylvania before the
Pennsylvania Public Utilities Commission
representing lowincome and elderly
individuals and
groups Mr Linder can you readj yeah
thank you
representative you got to kind of eat
the
apologize should I start again no thank
you okay all right uh during the time
that I represented clients before the
New Hampshire Public Utilities
Commission I had the opportunity since
1980 to work with and observe every New
Hampshire consumer
Advocate and learned a lot from them by
the way um I had three points that I
would like to make uh to
today um my written testimony goes into
more detail on these and other points
the three points that I would like to
make is that as I read House
Bill 610
FN it appears to me that the
OCA within a period of time will be
dissolved and the it will no longer be
an independent
agency and
that in
1981 when the OCA was created by Statute
RSA
36328 the legislature made clear that
the OCA was created as an independent
21-g called in
10 that is the
19 early
1980s statute that was part of the
executive reorganization act and part of
that act in section 10
G10
defines what
an an administratively attached agency
which the OCA is can do
and it made clear that the
administratively attached agency is to
make its own decisions on what issues it
raises before the Forum that it
appears and that is something that will
no longer happen in my opinion as I read
610 because the OCA
positions that get moved over there
whether it's three or five or
six they will
become either staff or employees of the
doe the department of
energy by
Statute the
RSA
12p is in Paul which is the Department
of energy statute makes clear that the
that the commissioner of the Department
of energy sets policy for all of the
agency and that the
commissioner oversees the work of both
the department heads and the staff of
the
agency assuming that the OCA position
becomes a staff position in the
doe if the OCA had a position that
differed from that of the established
policy of the commissioner of
doe it
seems
unlikely that the doe commissioner would
allow the
OCA to present that position at the
assuming that everyone's acting in good
faith with best intent but reasonable
Minds do differ on different points and
for whatever reason the commissioner's
policy and positions that the
commissioner establishes for the
Department uh may may not coincide with
what the
OCA would like its position to be so
is an OCA who is not really permitted to
continue to represent residential rate
payers as the
OCA position would like
to up until that's my first point my
second point is that up until
now in my observation the OCA
has done a very good and effective job
over at the Public Utilities Commission
on behalf of residential rate payers
this is my opinion now but I think that
in large part that's due to the fact
that the OCA up until now has been an
independent and allowed to express and
raise
positions and take positions and
present legal arguments on behalf of
residential rate payers that may not
always align with the other
parties um positions including the doe
and the Pu
point I think
consideration needs to be given to what
the consequences might be of moving the
OCA without its independence over to the
doe what might the consequences be to
the Public Utilities Commission itself
this may sound presumptuous but to
consequences prior
speaker mentioned that there is a
statute
RSA
the one thing that I think everyone
would agree on I think would be that
whoever is the judge whoever is the
Arbiter whoever are the decision makers
they need to be well
informed and the only way they can be
well informed
is
a information from their staff and B
information provided by the party ities
to a particular proceeding before the
commission if one of the parties who
regularly participates in commission
proceedings is not allowed to
express his or her views
as an OCA doe staff member then the
result will be that the commission will
not know know what concerns the consumer
the doe consumer Advocate really
has and will not know if the
OCA has a
position contrary to or not in alignment
with the doe position well the result in
my mind will be that the commission will
never
know and the one thing that's important
is when you have a number of diverse
parties it's essential to be able to
parse through their positions and legal
arguments if the if the consumer
Advocate is no longer allowed to put
forth his or her position on behalf of
residential Rays then we end up in my
opinion with an Arbiter decision maker
who doesn't have the information it's
been withheld from him I think
unintentionally withheld
from the decision maker by House Bill
610 but
nevertheless it's it's a restriction
that has been placed on the
Commissioners the
Commissioners are not allowed to have
all the information it's very difficult
to make a decision when you have all the
information all the facts and all law in
front of you but it it
undermines the role of arbiter I think
that the commission is assigned and the
commission whether we agree or not agree
with everything that it
decides it's
nevertheless trying to do its best with
what it has and House Bill 610 in my
view ties one hand behind their back the
OCA is a
nonvoice and I don't think that that is
really in the public interest and I hope
that the commit that this honorable
committee will take that into account
and I want to thank you for the
opportunity to make to present my
position thank you for your testimony
are there any
questions okay there no questions very
Beck B but not
Bruce there's a difference exactly thank
you sir yeah that's
okay uh good morning uh my name is Bruce
Burke I live in
Pittsfield uh I'm just an ordinary
taxpayer in the state and I thought I
would share a couple comments this
morning uh it strikes me again I'm not
an expert on distributive power what
should the Pu allow or not allow in
terms of allowances that ever Source can
get back that's all above my pay grade
um what strikes me as listening to
testimony today is uh I think it's
really unusual and I I've heard it twice
now that members of the
St from opposing
parties both believe this is a bad Bill
I mean that should be bottom line for
people people who who who swim in this
water all the time and that's their
judgment uh I also say the beginning
conversation I heard I think I heard the
prime sponsors say that Energy
Efficiency is an ideological
issue I'm just a taxpayer I don't know
why fighting for cheaper rates is an
ideological
issue um very quickly I really only have
two points one is um I think we learned
in Middle School that the New Hampshire
legislature is the second largest
legislature in the
world uh which to me means that we value
many
voices we pride ourselves on many
voices and so logically it occurs to me
that we should believe that in terms of
many voices independent
voices working for the benefit of
taxpayers um
second one is I I'm an Ever Source
customer uh you heard me I live in
Pittsfield you probably know a little
bit about Pittsfield we have really we
are struggling to and lots of families
struggling to uh balance paying our
bills etc etc etc so I just feel like uh
as just an ordinary citizen that I trust
an independent voice to make the best
decision for us the tax
taxpayers and I'm not
sure uh if the consumer Advocate becomes
part of the doe that they'll have that
kind of Independence you've heard it
before but as a person on ground level
that's my fear too uh I'd be happy to
take your questions uh but thank you for
the time and thank you for your
service thank you are there any
Alec
omor good morning uh for the record my
name is Alec Oma and I am the director
of external Affairs at
Unitil uh Unitil for those who may not
be familiar with us in the room uh as
this is not an energy committee we are a
gas and electric utility in the state of
New Hampshire we serve very specific
parts of the state we provide electric
service here in conquer we also provide
gas and electric service in the New
Hampshire Sea Coast Area uh Unitil has
no formal position on this bill but we
did want to come in and emphasize to you
uh what the value of this office is in
our opinion and what we believe it means
to the process and that comes back to
this concept of Independence that has
been talked about quite a bit today um
from our perspective as we go about
serving our customers uh our focus is on
trying to make sure we are using our
Distribution Systems in a manner that
enables the things that our customers
want to do while at the same time
ensuring that the energy we provide them
remains affordable and reliable it is a
balancing act that we are constantly
dealing with trying to make sure we're
doing in a way that takes into account a
wide array of stakeholders throughout
that process the office of the consumer
Advocate is a crucial part of that
process in that it has an independent
voice that represents the interests of
the rate payers and maintaining
affordability uh Independence has been
talked about a lot today I want to go
back to uh really underline the way that
I think representative Harrington put it
because that really aligns with what I
wanted to try and say today here is uh
we started off talking about
independence in terms of political
appointment and whether or there was
true Independence in that way uh I think
representative Harrington put it very
eloquently when he pointed out that
that's a little bit of a red herring
here what we're really talking about is
independence of
intent the Office of Consumer advocacy
has a specific intent which is to
represent the voice of the rate payer
throughout the process on energy matters
that can be before the Public Utilities
Commission that can be before the uh
legislators talking about policy matters
that can be work sessions that can be
communicating directly to us as a
utility in terms of points of view uh
that is one aspect as to what the
department of energy as a whole looks at
but we believe that that point of view
is very important and deserves to have
its own independent voice so independent
of intent as opposed to Independent of
overall political structure I think is
the important thing to focus on and we
would ask this committee to weigh the
value of that independent as they look
at this bill happy to answer any
questions you have thank you don't see
any questions think we've worn ourselves
out on the previous speakers
mcder good morning Madam chair and and
committee appreciate you listen to my
testimony my name is Patrick mcdermit
I'm the volunteer state president for
AARP New Hampshire and I'm here
representing our
212,000 New Hampshire
members I live in hookit New Hampshire
and I have more than four Decades of
electric utility experience here in the
state of New Hampshire I'm here to
testify against House Bill 610 which
would weaken the office of the consumer
Advocate as we've heard by placing it
within the department of energy
and by reducing its staff there's really
three main reasons we find this bill
problematic one has been talked about
quite a bit so I won't belabor it the
independence of the consumer Advocate is
crucial for Effective act Advocacy
number two advocacy for interest of
residential customers could be lost and
diluted we've heard that before as well
because the department of energy has so
many other
responsibilities thirdly cutting the
staff down to three would impede the
office's ability to protect residential
utility customers the current staff is
already quite small compared to the many
and numerous
lawyers um staff and Consultants
employed by utility
companies the uh one example that I like
to bring up very briefly is that the
complexity of the current eversource
rate case and that's distribution rate
case um delivery rate case which
includes a proposal to replace a
traditional ratemaking process with a
more much more complicated formula
demonstrates the importance of having a
robust Office of the consumer Advocate
to basically understand what's going on
and protect not only actually
residential customers but all customers
from these kind of changes this bill
would weaken the voices of customers of
consumers resulting in higher rates and
less transparent Arcy and accountability
in utility
regulation I think the choice is simple
if you support consumers and lowering
utility cost you need to vote no on this
legislation I also have written
testimony that goes into a little more
detail thank you we'll be glad to have
that any
questions don't see any thank you I
don't see
um good morning Madam chair and members
of the committee thank you for the
opportunity to testify today um my name
is Raymond Burke and I'm an attorney at
New Hampshire legal assistance no
relation to the Burke who previously
testified as far as I know um I'm here
today to provide this testimony in
opposition to hb610 um New Hampshire
legal assistance for those who don't
know is a Statewide nonprofit Law Firm
our attorneys and paralegals represent
low-income clients throughout the state
regarding various civil legal issues
including on behalf of clients in
dockets before the Public Utilities
Commission and in matters uh before the
department of energy regarding um
various utility uh related uh programs
um based on legal assistances experience
representing our low-income clients we
oppose this bill and encourage the
committee to recommend the bill in
expedient to legislate um in the
interest of time um I will just say I we
agree with much of what has been said by
others in opposition to this bill
notably representative Harrington Mr
Kirk um attorney Linder um we will just
mention that as a small nonprofit we
don't have the resources to get involved
in every docket before the Pu or uh
speak on every matter uh before the
department of energy that impacts um
low-income residential ratee payers um
we regularly have to turn away clients
who have meritorious cases in the
various work that we do um and so we
believe that as others have said it's
crucial to have um an independent Office
of Consumer Advocate whose sole mission
is to represent the interest of all
residential ratee payers um we just
can't uh match the resources that they
have we do get involved in rate cases on
behalf of our clients every now and then
but we don't have the funding to hire
the consultants and subject matter
experts needed um on every single issue
so often our focus is very narrow um and
we rely heavily on the work uh that the
consumer Advocate and its staff and
Consultants do um in in those cases
um and I think I just want to underscore
some of what others said just to to uh
highlight in in terms of rates it is the
Public Utilities Commission that's the
ultimate decider that the consumer
Advocate um doesn't control what the
rates are but our experience like others
in the dockets uh is that the office of
the consumer Advocate does uh strongly
um uh represent the interest of those
rate payers to to ensure um that rates
aren't uh increasing uh
unnecessarily um and and um we would
just uh be concerned as others have said
that that voice would go away if the
office is folded in with uh the
department of energy um and with that I
I know we're already far over so I'll
take questions if there are any but I
appreciate the opportunity to testify
thank you thank
just checking if I can still say good
morning uh good morning Michael Lata
representing eversource energy
appreciate the opportunity to testify
before you this morning just by way of
background eversource uh provides
electric distribution and transmission
service to 140 uh retail customers in
206 communities here in New Hampshire as
well as 180 uh I'm sorry 540,000 uh
100,000 residential customers as well as
180 uh thousand wholesale customers um I
I guess I'll be brief in my comments a
lot has been said uh I I do want to say
we do appreciate the intent to look at
the regulatory process and try to
identify ways to make it more efficient
and we certainly think that it is
appropriate for the legislature to
evaluate the roles of the Public
Utilities Commission the department of
energy as well as the consumer Advocate
now three years after the creation of
the Department of energy and there are
other pieces of legislation to look at
at the different roles and
responsibilities of those agencies uh we
do have concerns uh with the bill as it
has been introduced and are opposed uh
eversource as many others has testified
uh we believe that it is important to
have an independent office in state
government that represents the interest
of residential Ray payers uh matters
before the Public Utilities Commission
are technically complex and they are
adjudicated through quasi judicial
proceedings some of these proceedings
can last months and at times years and
that's why it's important for the
utility for the regulatory process and
most importantly for customers that
there is a voice and an advocate
representing the interest of residential
customers and that that uh Advocate is
independent of other state
agencies Our concern with the Bill's
approach is that it would make the
consumer Advocate and employee of the
Department of energy reporting to the
commissioner the doe is already an
active participant in proceedings before
the Public Utilities Commission and as
has been discussed their role is to
represent the public policy interests of
the executive branch Our concern is that
shifting the consumer Advocate under the
department of energy would give the
department of energy an oversized role
at these proceedings essentially you
would have one state agency with two
seats at the table there are times when
the positions of the Department of
energy and the consumer Advocate may be
similar but there are similar uh also
just as many times when they will will
differ as the public priorities of the
executive branch May differ from the uh
Financial interests of residential rate
payers the bill sponsor uh talked about
how there is an inherent adversarial
relationship between utilities and the
consumer Advocate and that is absolutely
correct uh there there is an appropriate
and healthy amount of tension if if both
the utility and the consumer Advocate
are doing their job and so it does beg
the question as he did ask uh why we
would be before you today expressing our
concerns uh about preserving the
independence of this office and to that
I would just say that like any business
utilities uh seek consistency and
certainty in Regulatory and statutory
processes and we believe that this bill
and it would represent a significant
change and have uh significant long-term
unintended consequences and with that
I'd be happy to answer any questions
that the committee may
have thank you I don't see any so very
n thank you madam chair and members and
I can still say good morning by two
minutes uh my name is Dana N I live in
samton I am the chair of the residential
rate payers Advisory Board appointed by
the governor to represent small
businesses I am in opposition to hb610
is it will be detrimental to New
Hampshire rate
payers I've been on in an intervenor on
numerous dockets at the Pu from 2004 to
2012 during these N9 years I became a
parent of the value of the Office of
Consumer Advocate excuse me I've have
also been collaborating with the office
the governor's office of energy and
Community Services which was named in
2000 and now it's the
doe and I can see that the independence
of the OC is very crucial unlike
neighboring states in New Hampshire the
OCA relies on the
independence changing the OCA from the
current independent status to operate
under the doe commissioner would only
disempower the OCA and its commitment to
serving the public good in 2020 and
2024 I have been a member and a chair of
a non-political committee to recommend
to the governor for the consumer
advocate for the next four years which
resulted in the reappointment of
attorney
Tre this
committee as it took six months we would
put put put out a survey to politicians
utilities nonprofit state employees and
to the public and with this survey
would' come back and make an an
assumption of what the people really
wanted for the consumer Advocate and it
always came out to Mr Cree to be
reappointed in conclusion as chairs The
Advisory Board in support of the OCA and
the residential rirs I request that h 3
610 go to
itl any questions I'd be glad to answer
okay thank you for your testimony thank
you don't see any
questions the advantage of coming late
alms and if I talk fast it's still good
morning uh good morning Madam chair
members of the committee for the record
I am Chris Elms I'm the Deputy
Commissioner the New Hampshire
Department of energy the department
takes no position on the bill uh as we
do view it as the legislature's
prerogative to determine the structure
of government um I will say that if if
this committee does want to move forward
uh with the bill we do uh see a little
bit of a lack of clarity uh on the
position transfer question that was
alluded to earlier in the hearing um we
would be happy to work with you if if
there are uh you you know just on on
what whatever it is that you want to
have happen so if there are existing
positions at the consumer Advocate that
you want to come to the department we
would probably have language to suggest
to make sure that that happens uh as
smoothly as possible our business office
um as sort of the uh agency to which the
OCA is administratively attached to
handles the back office functions for
both agencies and um would would help to
clarify uh whatever the intent of the
committee is uh happy to work with you
Andor the prime sponsor um but other
than that happy to take questions okay
thank you for that are there any any
questions representative
Pearson I'll break the mold for a
second the absorption of these positions
by the doe comes without
funding if I'm reading this right okay
so do you have the ability within the
budget that you guys run under to absorb
these
positions without having an additional
funding source to provide for those
positions uh I it's a good question
thank you representative I think uh that
really does to to my point earlier
depend on whether or not you want to
transfer the existing positions uh
within the consumer Advocates office to
the department or whether or not you are
abolishing those positions and creating
new ones um if if you are simply
transferring all it's the same funding
source uh for the consumer Advocate as
it is for the Department of energy so we
would see that it's simply a transfer um
but that's again up to the committee uh
right now the bill is unclear what the
intent
is but if the positions were to be
abolished you would need a different
funding source is that correct correct
unless we were uh the intention was that
we repurposed existing positions which
we would have you know obviously we have
our work to to get done so okay thank
you
Pearson okay okay are there any other
questions for the for the
commissioner no okay thank
you let's see Matt Mayberry stepped
out EMA the committee his
testimony
okay is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill
610 all right seeing none I'm going to
close the hearing we will not be voting
on this because we have a large stack of
of T written testimony to read through
before we make any kind of
decisions and the committee will resume
at 1 p.m. can we retain that one so the
cler doesn't oh yes sorry we have one
small bit of committee uh business that
we've been asked to take care of before
lunch House Bill
525 which we heard last
week uh I said we were going to retain
it but forgot to actually take the vote
so I'm moving we go into executive
session and I vote to retain House Bill
525 I'll second at that okay moved by me
second by representative Lon is there
any
discussion thank you for allowing me to
keep my promise those in favor oh sorry
the uh clerk will call the roll yeah you
want it roll call not just we normally
do it's it's our normal
process could you do it
okay for
practice the uh Vice chairman L yes the
clerk FKS yes representative Pearson yes
representative Bailey yes representative
sh yes representative sers yes
representative yes
representative not here representative
Roda yes representative Schmidt
not here representative uh Davis yes
representative Dary yes representative
Howard yes representative re
yes U
representative uh long has been replaced
by representative Lane who is not here
representative Lane is in fact I'm
sorry and how do you vote
yes okay and the chair yes okay looks
like uh 14 to zero thank you for letting
me keep my promise we will be back at 1M
after lunch Madam chair can I add one
piece of information I ran into the
director of the retirement system
downstairs and to answer a question that
occurred on Monday whether the fiscal
analysis took into effect current law
they did catch the mistake and the
fiscal note was conducted with current
law and not the error in 727 excellent
I'm glad that caught that
e
okay for planning purposes
committee we're going to do as as many
we're going to exec as many bills as we
can today as we're ready we and then
we're going to do all the rest of
them next week
provided uh because that that'll give us
time to get the reports in prior to the
deadline we can slip one or two if we
have to but I really hope we don't have
to
um and after that at this point I don't
know of anything until we start getting
so all right
and all right we
have representative Howard okay we have
first house bill
specifically noticed for this executive
session representative Howard do you
have a
motion yes uh I move ought to pass with
Amendment uh
for yes oh well I thought that we had to
have POS first motion is to adopt
Amendment 0617 H I think yes correct
okay
um yes uh and to speak to the amendment
I was expecting a second sorry is there
a second I'll second I'll I'm
sorry so uh to speak to the amendment uh
this amendment it does some uh pretty
basic changes it changes uh one of the
requirements of the committee uh to uh
have a member of executive departments
and administration uh be a part uh of
the commission and it would also change
things uh specifically uh section three
part C and D it would allow ow the
commission to develop criteria process
for accepting and a deadline for
submission of flag designs and it would
then allow the commission to determine
how many designs they want to consider
and how to narrow down the number uh of
design submissions uh that kind of
covers it and I hope for your support
thank you uh representative Howard what
date apparently it's what the original
bill is but I afraid I don't have that
in front of me yes I apologize I'm
apologize for not having it
handy um takes
um so the intent is to do all of this
this
year it says the commission shall report
its findings and any recommendations for
the proposed legislation to the Speaker
of the House the president of the Senate
the house Clerk bahah and the New
Hampshire Historical Society on before
November 1
2025 okay that's so that says you're
year okay does that repeal the bill and
is there there a repeal or not yes it
repeals on November 1 2025 okay so the
report and the repeal are this year EXC
excellent thank you for having
that
um yes we have we are considering the
amendment that you co-sponsored to House
Bill 210 well then you know my
position yes exactly is there any um is
anyone else represent grot do you wish
us speak to your
second no I do believe that the
amendment covers the things that we
discussed in the committee okay is there
question okay seeing none represent cic
call the role on the
amendment Vice chairman Leon yes the
clerk votes yes representative Pearson
yes representative uh Bailey I
representative she
yes representative SL uh sers yes
representative sloty
yes representative groden yes
representative Schmid
I representative Davis yes
representative Dary
yes representative Howard yes
representative Tes yes representative
15 okay representative Howard we have a
motion yes I'd like to move uh House
Bill 210 uh as amended and I'll second
that Amendment with Amendment with with
Amendment apologies as we stand
corrected yes with
Amendment uh is there a second yeah it
would be
me okay do you wish to speak to your
motion no I'll wave okay represent
pearison I think it was covered um for
the most part with a lot of the
discussions that have happened already
and uh again just just as a reminder
this does not necessarily mean that
anything is being changed it's just
providing a mechanism to take a look and
if we decide we want to keep things the
way they are so be it
okay Lon uh thank you madam chair I
personally really like the current New
Hampshire flag um if everybody decides
to have a commission and go through the
process I understand that but I like the
flag so that's why I won't be voting for
the bill as amended but I understand why
others
would anyone else have a comment
question
concern I'd like to say that I'm not
sure that a uh a six-month commission
will do much good
but representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair
remember if this Commission comes up
with a proposal that we like we will
support it if we don't like it no matter
how much the theory of looking at the
situation because it's going to be the
current flag against whatever proposal
is is offered by the commission if we
like the new proposal
better then we then it makes sense to go
in that direction if we don't like it we
know what we've
got thank
you okay okay anyone else
comments okay in that case a motion is
ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill 210 and the clerk can call the role
Vice chairman Leon no the clerk votes
yes representative Pearson yes
representative Bailey
I representative Shi yes representative
sers yes representative slaty uh yes
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt yes um representative Davis yes
representative dargy yes uh
representative Howard yes representative
D.A re yes representative Lane yes and
the
chair sorry Erica yes fine I'll move
consent all right does anyone the motion
passes 14 to one any objections to
consent okay we'll put this one on
consent
and I will pray that our P
fixologist Vel does not come back with a
slightly tweaked flag design next year
all right um so anybody remember 14 to
bir yeah well we've done that too okay
uh the licensing sub committee met so we
have a few other bills we can uh vote on
in a few for a few minutes
representative grod you have yes I do
thank you Madame chair I would like to
move amendment
0439 to House Bill
271 and I have copies for us here oh you
welome is there a second while we're
wait a
BR uh just a moment I may not be that
let me um if I could retract that um
that motion and make another to a
different
bill um I'd like to move amendment
05778 to House Bill
82 and I'll pass out that Amendment if
you could just get rid of the uh let's
not confuse this confuse the clerk is
there a reason not to do this one well
it's the
wrong the this is the wrong wrong
Amendment this is the wrong amendment
number and we have the wrong Amendment
printed so that's why I'm so all right
so so this is being withdrawn thank you
all right so that's just out I'm sorry
yes I'd like to withdraw that Amendment
sorry sorry about that the mo motion and
the second are withdrawn because they
think the amendment is the wrong one
okay this is an amendment to House Bill
82 moved by representative BR and
seconded by representative Pearson
you okay representative gr groa do you
wish to speak to your motion yes so uh
during testimony of the oplc bills you
might recall that there was concern
raised on the um managing of the
background
checks and the hesitancy for the
background checks to be sent to the
office as opposed to a particular person
so the language that is in here
regarding background
checks um criminal history background
checks is from the Department of Safety
and in conjunction between the
department of safety and the oplc
attorney so this is the language that
was
drafted um in the in the and in the
uh other parts of the bill let me just
go
back there were some um amend there were
some changes that were made
regarding uh section 39 that had to do
with
electricians the amendment says that um
the the
examination at their at their expense um
can
be they can take it over and if they've
not passed the examination with within
one year of the office receiving their
application then it's assumed that they
don't want to further continue and the
re ah so that after one year they have
to submit a new application yes
oh yes you might remember that there was
a discussion about the radiation therapy
section and that if one license could
apply to all
modalities and this was done in that was
taken up in the amendment this was part
of uh chair Maguire's Amendment to the
original bill so that change was
incorporated in this amendment as
well not as elegantly I might say but
it's there well I I appreciate you also
took care of the uh high school diploma
yes yes that's right um so I think those
are the changes that that uh were
adopted in this amendment and passed by
the subcommittee recommended by the
subcommittee
okay
or thank you madam chairwoman um
question sorry I wasn't clear about the
radiation therapy where's that SE and
what what has it changed since last
time I believe it's new yes it's a new
section and it is on page four it's
section 44 where it says Medical Imaging
lure thank you you're
welcome any other qu uh representative
Pearson do you have anything to add no
any any other questions comments I don't
he was the second representative Pearson
yep that's why I asked him sure um I'd
like to thank you for for incorporating
the the problems that we found at the
hearing and also the
extra
um extra language that we needed so
much and this was recommended by the
subcommittee
okay anyone else
questions
comments all right um in that case the
motion is to accept Amendment 5778 to
House Bill 82 and the clerk can call the
rule representative Vice chairman Lon
yes clerk puts yes representative
Pearson yes representative baile
I representative of Sheen yes
representative sers yes representative
slaty
yes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative Davis yes representative
Dar
yes representative Howard yes
representative
yes uh representative Lane yes and
that's 15 to zer for adopting Amendment
do I get a vote I'm sorry it's the first
time I did that that's okay I'm voting
yes okay as you counted yeah all right
no hitters so far all right
representative grto you have a
motion I do I'd like to move Amendment
05 perhaps we should do o to pass with
Amendment
on yes can we do OTP yes I'd like to
move a pass with Amendment on House Bill
82 excellent is there a second okay do
you wish to say
anything on your motion I think not I'd
like no I'd like to wave that
representative
Pearson no no I think we're I think
we're good we did spend the subcommittee
did spend quite a bit of time hashing
this out over multiple uh actually took
us more than one session to do that so
we uh we're pretty confident in how this
is so thank you and I'd like to report
to the committee that this
is as far as I know and as far as oplc
says the last of the statutory cleanup
that we that we struggled with last
session I've heard that before yes of
course you've heard that before but but
if they're coming up with another one
I'm not going to support it all right um
any other comments
questions we pick motion is ought to
82 call the rooll represent uh Vice
chairman L yes CLK votes yes
representative Pearson yes
representative Bailey I representative
Shen yes representative sers yes
representative yes representative
Gro yes representative Schmidt yes
represent representative Davis yes
representative Dary yes representative
Howard yes representative yes
representative Lane yes and the chair
yes thank you
15o
okay motion passes 15 to Zer is there
any objection to
consent seeing none we'll put that on
consent and
um representative Gro you have another
motion I do Madame chair I'd like to
move
amendment
0564 to health Bill
145 which is the
dietician Compact and um background
checks
okay is there a
second yeah I'll second that okay and I
have a I have copies you have the
okay so this is
the new preferred language for criminal
background checks
correct it is on its way to
representative
schm we have not forgotten about you I
what's he talking
about all right uh representative gr you
wish to speak to your M
yes thank you madam chair the concern
that the um committee had with the
previous bills concerning background
checks were were addressed and this is
similar language this is a language that
we're using for all um lenses and um
that require background checks it was
discussed that we should make this a
practice under the general RSA for the
oplc but the response from the
Department of Safety was that they
requested that we put it under each
individual licenses which is why it
appears
here um but the rest of it has not
changed so the compact remains as it was
submitted to the committee
okay representative
parison that's exactly what happened
excellent any other questions or
comments okay the motion is to adopt
amendment
0564 to House Bill 145 and the clerk can
call the role Vice chairman L yes clerk
votes yes representative peon yes
representative Bailey I representative
shim yes representative sers yes
representative yes representative
groda yes representative Schmidt yes
representative Davis yes representative
dargy yes
representative Howard yes representative
dver re yes representative Lane yes and
the chair yes okay 1 15 on the adoption
okay representative Gera you have a
motion then the motion the amendment is
adopted I move um a to pass with
Amendment on House Bill
145 is there a
second
here all right do you wish to speak to
your motion
the um testimony that was presented to
the committee concerning the
compact um demonstrated for the for the
need for this contact in the example of
the woman who pays licensing fees in
multiple States and although it's not it
may be that the states that are involved
in this compact are not all-encompassing
it does reduce the cost of having a
multi-state compact I'm licensed for a
particular profession therefore I would
support this I would recommend the
committee support this bill okay
represent Pearson do you to speak to
your
second uh sure the the amendment part we
just talked we just covered that dealt
with the background check part of that
which is actually separate from the
compact um the conditions of that my
concern was that if we made an
adjustment we would affect an existing
compact that is not the case so we're in
the clear there the other thing is that
this bill just a reminder it's it h it's
a privilege to practice model so that it
is possible to be able to do this
outside of the compact in New Hampshire
so you the folks that do this that have
no desire to be part of that don't have
to be part of that so which is a little
unusual because other compacts are kind
of you're in it it just is so in this
case um they they they've got a lot of
freedom here so um cleaning up the
background check part we're we're
confident that that's going to take care
of the concerns that happened this is
language that came out of the Department
of Education that has already been
vetted through the FBI they already
existing they use it in the Department
of Education so we're presuming and
hoping that that should be okay if we're
doing it in another agency so um other
than
that it's uh it it is as it was in the
hearing representative lamb um thank you
madam chair um I just want to clarify
this is not yet been adopted by enough
states to be active is that
correct so what happens with compacts
and we've seen this time and time again
here is there
is there's an incentive to to be the
ones that make it go if you will right
because it seems as though all of these
compacts are structured in a way that
the
first depending on how many states it
requires say as an example if it
requires Nine States to be ratified the
first nine get a seat at a at a bigger
table if you will right because that
table then has more of like an executive
board type role in some of the decisions
that go on with adjusting and modifying
the
compact
um it's it's the structure of the
compact exists as it is they they're not
it's not a restructuring but it's it's a
tweaking of some things so so what
happens with that is is there is a huge
advantage to being at the table the big
boy table if you will table in the first
group correct in in the sense of the
executive board level um that would be
and that's covered in in the compact it
it actually specifies and outlines how
that works so the the the concern that I
always have with compacts is what what
is New Hampshire's ability to get out of
a compact because we've had to do that
before as well and that as we heard in
testimony and as I highlighted here on
page 20 we have the ability to withdraw
from this Compact and um that is um
that's just an important element at
least to me where the compact has the
ability through its executive board to
tweak and modify potentially to the
point where the the folks in New
Hampshire go you know what we're out we
don't we don't like this so um this this
has that in it other compacts that we've
been ENT entered into in the past have
had a more complicated process to
withdraw so uh in that case here um
that's great the military spouses are
also as specifically addressed in this
compact um which is great
that clarifies some muddy water that you
get into sometimes as far as what is a
home state and um their ability to
function within the compact in the sense
that they're mobile due to their
military
commitments beyond that I mean it's uh
like I said it's it's as it was
presented in the hearing repres um thank
you with that it my question would be if
um the going changing from a privilege
to practice compact to one where you're
required to have lure if that's
something that would be an easy change
and then we would be facing a tital wave
of then leaving this compact if uh if if
we don't like the terms I'm very
concerned about about that issue because
if it you're able to change those terms
which it can and it hasn't yet been set
if the other states that come on board
require the lure of this practice in
order to be part of the compact that's
something that would concern me
significantly so that's up to the state
of New Hampshire in this case because
yes except if we've accepted the policy
of doing this and that this is a great
way to license all of this and everybody
who is licensed by loves it then it's a
significant uphill battle at that point
it's just my concern that um once you
get the momentum going it's pretty hard
to stop it that's a personal concern on
interstate compacts we don't really need
to debate that more but this is one of
compacts okay in the in the sense that
we have a provision to for Licensing in
New Hampshire outside of the compact
which we have the authority to do
actually with all compacts you just
don't the benefit of a compact if you
are not in under their conditions you
just operate here with in the sense of
lacking reciprocity anywhere else W
which is a self-imposed circumstance in
this case if you choose not to meet the
conditions of of any compact um in this
case the state of New Hampshire is
saying we we allow provision for that
whereas in some compact like the EMS
compact was the same way when we entered
into that we still retain New Hampshire
licenses people still operated here you
didn't have to participate in the
compact if you chose not to so I no
other state has the authority to dictate
to to us to not allow an
intrastate licensing that that's solely
up to the individual
State what right and so I recognize that
I just don't appre I I don't personally
like consolidating power outside of the
state it's that's my point of view got
okay I got thank you sure okay anyone
anyone else representative I kind of
feel the same way but representative
Pearson has alled my concerns okay I'd
like to comment that I'm going to vote
against this because I disapprove of the
compact the way it is written we are
signing up today to have their the
compact rules have the effect of law in
New Hampshire and we don't know what
they are I believe that's
unconstitutional um various and I'm not
going to vote for for any compact that
has has that in there this one is
particularly aggravating because the
rules haven't yet been written if we
were
to have a vote on the nurse compact for
example we know what the rules are we've
seen them they exist this case we don't
know what they are and we are requiring
ourselves to um to obey them represent
zch can't we get out of it sure well
then what's the harm we can if we can
well it's my
personal okay contention that our
constitution F forbids us from adopting
any rule not approved by our
Representatives by the people or their
elected representatives and this is that
case the fact that we can backtrack is
irrelevant in my opinion I may be wrong
but that's how I feel in that case then
in this particular case if we were one
of the
initiating we are we are one of the
states that is involved in the rul
making process um
but I guess then under under your
premise
then we would
never the state of New Hampshire would
never sit on an executive board of a
compact then because you would want that
figured out and then we decide whether
we would op wrong but but the other
point I want to make which may or may
not be convincing is that we have a very
robust reciprocity or Lure by
endorsement so we can bring outof State
dietitians in with a very simple process
get them licensed they can work here
this compact is to allow New Hampshire
dietitians to work elsewhere and so I'm
not convinced it's necessarily for the
it may be good for the individuals I
can't deny that but uh that's that's a
secondary Point comment I just want make
a comment
that the re the robust reciprocity is
true however they still have to pay a
licensing fee in two states or three
states or whatever so this basically
consolidates um the payment of one
license for many States whatever states
are part of the compact so I think that
is helpful to those lenses and
particular the women who I think pays a
license in 10 states no so that's a
significant cost to
her
yes that's what the people who came to
the hearing were testifying that they
liked having one license instead of many
else all all right in that case the
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
on House
Bill 145 and the clerk can call the
rooll vice chairman Le
no the clerk votes yes I me hopes he's
right representative Pearson yes
representative Bailey nay representative
Shan
no Representative sers no representative
SL
NOP representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative Davis yes representative
Argie yes representative Howard yes
Representative Steve Ares yes
representative Lane
yes
um and the chair
no four
six six two four
six8 nine nine to six in
favor is nine the
eight I don't we have 15 here yeah yeah
have 15 so it's nine to six 9 to six
okay n okay the motion passes 9- six it
will not be on
consent uh does someone wish to write a
Minority Report I can write The Minority
Report okay representative Leon will
write a Minority Report and
representative Grotto will write the
majority
report
okay and it is now being time for our
our hearing I will close the executive
session might like to know we ex 31
[Music]
this
yum
yum here is our
sponsor
okay um thank you I will open the
hearing on House Bill 161 and call the
Maguire good afternoon committee I'm
Carol Maguire representing the towns of
Allenstown Dunbarton Epsom and Hooksett
and House Bill 161 is this year's
attempt
to uh fix the new the commission on
Native American Affairs which has
been an issue before this committee for
quite some time um it this version was
put in on behalf of former
representative Sher
Gould and she can explain the details it
is intended to be a simpli
simplification and a focus of the of the
commission
and I will try to answer questions but I
may not be able
to thank you are there any questions
from the
committee thing none thank you very much
thank you and if you'll excuse me I'll
go present some of our bills to finance
thank you very much uh next I will call
good afternoon Madam chair and honorable
members of the committee it's nice to be
back with
you I'll start for the record by
introducing myself I'm Sher G from waren
New Hampshire I'm the special project
genealogist from the cultural and
historical preservation
department of the nohan ban of the kak
abanaki nation a legal state recognized
tribe I'm Vice chair of the board for
the state recognized tribal artist Guild
called
CAG and and you have this on the tan
hand out I sent around and I'm not
reading the whole testimony
um I am a former Trustee of the mount
kiraj gind Museum a sixth generation
traditional abanaki basket maker
formerly jured by the league of New
Hampshire Craftsman and currently jured
by the abanaki artist Association and
sirag and on the list of traditional
arts and folk life artists for the New
Hampshire State Council on the Arts I
served marac District 8 as a
representative to the general court
assigned to the Edna committee for 2023
and
2024 I was the genealogist appointed by
the New Hampshire genealogical Society
to the first New Hampshire Commission on
Native American Affairs in 2010 when it
was established and then I was elected
chairman of the commission when the
first chair term
expired so we would like to thank uh
chair Carol Maguire for bringing this
bill forward and for rep wheer and rep
Reed who co-sponsored the
bill so
um I think that the committee is going
to hear testimony that may seem a bit
confusing um American Indian law is
complex and it's not well
understood many of us have been
approached by Family close friends and
Neighbors in the last days letting us
know they signed into the portal to
oppose the evil
bill that um allows uh that would turn
things over to the evil state of Vermont
there's been some active social media
campaigns that report that this bill
does many bad things including those two
uh many of which aren't even in the bill
so I'm going to try to keep my testimony
to the scope of the bill which is simply
how we appoint um members to the
commission on Native Affairs and and
yeah it's it's a change in process and
some
qualifications so there's a couple of
pieces in my testimony you'll find and
I'll email this out to the committee
later there's links to all kinds of
websites where you can get all the facts
uh the details for Native American
law but there's two books I'll draw your
attention to and one is American Indians
in the law by uh Dr and Bruce duu and
we're very fortunate to have him at
Dartmouth he's an expert in and law
relating to tribal sovereignty and
political relations with state and
federal governments and the first
paragraph out of his book I think sets a
really good stage for what we're going
to talk about
today at their core most legal disputes
involve conflicts over power money or
respect or some combination of those
elements the legal battles involving
American Indian tribes are particularly
volatile since they often involved
challenges relating to all three of
these
areas This Book used uses the lens of
federal law relating to Indian tribes to
tell the story of this nation's historic
struggles to respond to a fundamental
question what is the proper place of
Indian tribes within America's
constitutional
framework most Americans who think of
it regard Indian tribes as distinct
racial groups who surface in the
National Consciousness around
Thanksgiving or in connection with
controversies over supporting team
mascots or in debates surrounding casino
gambling few Americans know that Indian
tribes have a legal status unique among
America's distinct racial or ethnic
groups they are also Sovereign
governments who engage in governmental
relations with Congress the United
States Constitution expressly provides
that Congress has power to regulate
commerce with foreign Nations and among
the several States and with the Indian
tribes
trying to make sense of this single
constitutional provision is a Central
purpose of this book and it goes into
the many complexities of Indian law at
the federal level a second paper that
you'll find a link to is uh where it
talks in my handout about
66 state recognized tribes have been
recognized by 11 different states it'll
link you to this paper federalism and
the state recognition of Native American
tribes a survey of state recognized
tribes
and the state recognition process across
the United States and that was published
by the Santa Clara law review in
2008 and I did ask Dr duu if there was
anything better or more modern and other
than his book which was also published
in 2008 he said that this was the best
Authority on state
recognition in the last few years States
and tribes have increasingly realized
that state recognition can serve as an
important Al Limited alternative to
Federal recognition this realization is
evidenced by the many states that have
recently certified their state
recognition process or are planning to
implement recognition processes to
facilitate communication between State
and tribal governments and better the
condition of tribal members and
surrounding communities State
recognition can also provide tribes with
limited state and federal benefits and
they use an example but I'll give you um
the best example is the Indian arts and
crafts act which is a federal law that
as soon as a tribe is recognized
anywhere in the country then all members
of that tribal groups so abanaki in our
case have to comply with the Indian arts
and crafts act to sell their arts and
crafts so that's the kind of limited
nature we're not federal tribes get a
lot of benefits they get money they get
gambling rights they get all kinds of
things state recognized tribes have none
of that but they do have a government
toover relationship consequent ly
several tribes are now bidding for State
recognition and many states are
implementing or strengthening processes
for acknowledging the tribes within
their
borders so you may wonder why I'm
talking about recognition because it
seems to go beyond the scope of this
bill except that what this bill does is
currently there are no members of
recognized tribes on the commission and
applications of recognized tribal
members to the commission have not
resulted and people being Seated on the
commission and so uh and then last year
we heard testimony in this committee
when the commission came forward and
stated that the Indian arts and crafts
bill doesn't apply to the state of New
Hampshire and I was tasked by the
committee to check with the Indian arts
and crafts board to find out if that was
so and indeed federal law does applied
in New Hampshire like the other 50
states so I I think it's really
important that uh we all we think it's
really important that the people that
sit on the commission are people that
are subject to the complex laws and
understand them and can better prepare
the state and the the state departments
um the when the New Hampshire commission
so the the other thing you'll probably
hear about you know and I I made
reference to it is that we're evil
Vermont Indians so I was born in New
Hampshire as were was my mother and and
my ancestors going back to very very
early
days in 2010 there were two bills
happening on either side of the state
and for Stu I mean of the river both
States New Hampshire and Vermont and for
students of History you may realize that
New Hampshire and Vermont was one area
and it was after the revolution before
the state of Vermont broke away from New
Hampshire and our tribal land has always
been New Hampshire and Vermont so his
historically the two states have been
connected for abanaki people of course
today there's a big difference between
politics in Vermont and politics in New
Hampshire but uh for us as native people
we have kin on both sides of the river
so in 2010 there was a bill in both the
New Hampshire house and in the Vermont
legislature and the one in New Hampshire
originally was presented to recognized
the abanaki and created a commission on
Native Affairs one of the things I
learned in my time in the legisl is that
we have a motto my husband says it
should be the new state motto that is
now is not the time and what we learned
was in 16 in uh 2010 for House Bill 1610
the legislature felt like now was not
the time to recognize the abanaki but it
was the time to form a commission on
Native Affairs so we got that done
Vermont on the other hand decided now is
the time for them to recognize the
abanaki so prior to Vermont recognizing
their four tribes in 201
we were just all an ethnic group a
minority group subject to the full
jurisdiction of the United States but as
soon as that law got passed in Vermont
that was when federal law impacted me
and I would be illegal to do what I had
been doing if I hadn't been fortunate to
be kin to the people in the Vermont
tribes and be allowed to enroll in those
tribes so this notion that I'm somehow
an evil Vermont Indian now who's trying
to do some harm to New Hampshire Indians
is troubling it's harm it hurts I'm not
it's not
so uh so at any rate since 2010 the
commission ran along quite well the last
five years is when we've started to see
these problems and more uh recently I I
passed around um some information from
darl Peasley he was a former I was
elected or I was appointed as the
genealogist on the first commission the
law used to have a genealogist appointed
and I was um chairman of the board
chairman of the uh commission after um I
served as Vice chairman Daryl Peasley is
here he's doesn't intend to speak but he
did pass around had me pass around some
information for you he served on the
commission as well and he was vice
chairman at the end of his term and darl
has applied and been informed that the
nomination committee did not forward his
uh recommendation to be appointed though
he was praised for his previous service
and said he was an excellent
candidate and then there's letters in
there from uh two of the chiefs of
tribes in Vermont who have citizens who
live in New Hampshire a residents of New
Hampshire advocating for their residents
who live here and like I said that
doesn't mean that they're Vermont
Indians who crossed the river and came
to New Hampshire some maybe but the
majority are New Hampshire residents who
have always been New Hampshire
residents so in closing I'll just say
that
um one of the things when uh that I
learned on this committee and some of us
were talking at lunchtime about how much
you learn right once you get in here and
and see how the law works I learned a
great deal about boards and commissions
because this committee handles so many
of them and I learned about the
difficulty of the governor making
appointments to the you know many of the
Committees and commissions complain
about the difficulty of getting people
appointed so this bill will change the
appointment process and this was
something we had a meeting we were very
fortunate to have some leadership from
the House and Senate meet with a group
of us and and some of these other groups
that are not recognized were invited to
attend the group but they they
declined at that meeting after hearing
what the issues have been the speaker of
the house was the one who recommended
that he would be willing to make the
appointment if the chiefs of the tribes
sent nominations to him that was not our
idea but it sounded it made perfect
sense to us so um that's you'll see that
bill but the other piece is and this is
a bit of a simplification but to help
you understand the issue you deal with a
lot of boards and commissions you deal
with the licensing boards for plumbers
for doctors for many things if you think
about a plumbers board and you think
about you know there's a lot of people
around that do plumbing and they they do
a pretty good job of their own plumbing
familes plumbing what have you but
they're not licensed plumbers with the
notion of having a plumbers board
without a single licensed plumber and in
fact licensed plumbers who oppose
licensing sit on the licensing board for
plumbers make sense to this committee I
think not I think you wouldn't want to
do that likewise if you had
medical healers who use plant medicine
but they weren't Physicians that work in
hospitals and they didn't believe in
Physicians that worked in hospitals
would you allow them to occupy the
medical board and not let doctors on the
on the board so those are the things I'd
like to leave you with to think
about um we ask you to support House
Bill 61 to assist us in moving ahead oh
there's one additional responsibility
that this bill also has and that is to
study recommendation so this bill does
not do anything other than to task the
commission to study the topic of
recognition and make a report back to
the general court um at the end of the
year and that's all I have to say does
anybody have any questions I'll be happy
to take some thank you other questions
from the committee representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair question
of the chair uh do we have anybody
paying attention to whether we have have
online attendance if you will uh today
on this bill um ordinary representative
Howard has been monitoring whether we
have people who are online he will
probably check at some point if we don't
have that by the time that we're done
remind me again if he's not back in the
room to check that well he is here he is
so if he's here I will leave that to the
members as we move forward in our
discussion because there's people who
are watching this online who may still
be registering their opinions are there
questions um of
The
Honorable yes representative re thank
you madam chair um representative G is I
know that you're a former state
representative so is that how I'm
supposed to address you representative G
yeah uh honorable honorable The
Honorable honorable G honorable gold
thank you very much I want to make sure
that I got that right um my question has
to do with on the bill on page one um on
lines 12 and 13 and I'm hoping that you
can just bring this down um and really
simplify it for me and this is my lack
of uh understanding of relations uh
within the state of New Hampshire and
federally so it says um only enrolled
tribal citizens who reside in New
Hampshire shall be nominated by the
chiefs
of the state recognized abanaki or
federally recognized tribes and then a
couple lines down from that it says
members of the abanaki tribe tribes
recognized by the state of Vermont and
federally recognized tribes in New
England are published in the Federal
Register dot do dot so is is the reason
is I'm so sorry abanaki people not
recognized by the federal government
correct there are no federally
recognized tribes and I I I I do explain
that in the full testimony on the cream
colored paper that excuse me there's a a
website that I connect you to for the
Bia and that's where all federal
recognition petitions are listed and
they have three different sections
there's anyone who may have applied but
they're waiting for more paperwork to go
in and then there's another page that
has those who are currently in process
and open to public comment and then
there's those that are adjudicated so
they've been denied or approved and
you'll see if you go to all three of
those pages there's nobody from New
Hampshire who has applied for federal
recognition and um and no abanaki now
there was an abanaki group from Vermont
that had applied for federal recognition
a while ago and they were denied um and
that was prior to the state recognition
happening in Vermont so the whole notion
is that what the speaker said was that
if Chiefs of recognized tribes made
nominations to him then he would select
from that pool and that he wanted to see
both state recognized and federally
recognized residents so the way that got
wor worded and I apologize I'm I I know
it's in this pile somewhere my copy of
the bill but uh that
only recognized tribal members really
the only re refers to residents of New
Hampshire we wanted to it to be clear
that only residents of New Hampshire who
are enrolled in federal or state
recognized tribes would be um nominated
to the speaker for um consideration to
be appointed to the commission does that
answer that for you you could have a
followup
thank
you so I process a little slowly
sometimes so so because AB that's the
reference to Vermont in this bill is
because the abanag is not recognized by
the federal government but is recognized
by by state of that is the reason that
the state of ran is specifically
referenced here so that people have
abanaki people can be nominated by the
speaker to serve on the commission
correct it is the government
authorization or the government
acknowledgement that we are a tribe that
makes us fall under title 25 so Indian
is defined and it is Indian not Native
American is defined under title 25 as a
member of a tribe and tribe is defined
under title 25 as um an political entity
that is recognized by a government and
then there's and most of what title 25
pertains to is federal recognition so
it's government to government at the
federal level State recognition is a
state recognizes a
tribe that gives that tribe government
state to government relationships with
the state that recognizes it but it also
makes it a political entity with certain
rights so the right to sell my baskets
in New Hampshire is protected because I
am enrolled in a recognized tribe it
doesn't matter what state recognized it
but New Hampshire departments have said
to me in the past when I've tried to
talk to them our tribe has an agreement
with the federal government that we can
carry bird Parts eagle feathers or other
migratory bird parts now that's not a
right that the general citizens have but
because we're enrolled in a political
entity we have that agreement so I
wanted to meet with fishing game just to
make sure that we were all on the same
page to avoid any misunderstandings if
tribal members are seen with um with
bird feathers and the response was New
Hampshire doesn't recognize any tribes
so that's why we'd like to start that
discussion we hope in the future that
New Hampshire is ready that now will be
the time to recognize tribes but in it's
the details of tribal recognition in New
Hampshire are outside the scope of this
bill just the
concept uh another followup thank you
very much um so to make sure that I'm
fully who is sitting on the commission
currently um I think some of them are
here they can better speak to who they
are great thank you so much I do have um
this I can pass out they may pass it out
but it's a it's just a copy of the
website for the commission on Native
Affairs it shows who's appointed and um
and there are currently five empty seats
and so we did do some work last year to
fix the quum issue but there were other
parts where like I said they had wanted
to remove reference to the federal law
from the bill and we didn't the that did
not pass thank you so much um thank you
given that this is about recognition and
only abanaki who have ties to Vermont
can be recognized in the recognized by
Vermont abanaki uh do you think that
there may be some potential to also
include those um who would be able to be
a member after the state of New
Hampshire recognizes the ab yes that's
been our hope and our prayer and our
goal from day one is that New Hampshire
would provide a path for all groups who
meet the criteria whatever that winds up
being and yes that this would get
revised and I almost see this like an
inter measure as we get that process set
up because my sense is really and
sincerely that there is a will to
recognize the abanaki that these old
fears you know some of the fears you
heard me read in those excerpts came
from 2008 I think that the commission's
done a a good job in just this hearing
the bills and and me having lunch blah
blah blah for two years with people
people has um really helped people to
understand that the abanaki are here we
always have been here and uh and I think
the state's ready to do this and I would
love to see every group in New Hampshire
become recognized that wants to they
don't all want to and so as a followup
then there are other groups as well who
don't have recognition correct in both
Vermont and New Hampshire correct thank
you correct that's very helpful um are
there other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much before I call the next person I do
want to let everybody who is here for
the dental bill let you know that we
still have four people to call for the
prior bill um so we will be getting to
you but we won't be getting to you at
two o'clock um thanks next I will call
please good afternoon Madam chair and
honorable committee
members I'm Jenny tibits I am a tribal
Elder NE noock
which is a subtribe of the Penacook
tribe which is located in was now
Southeastern New Hampshire rollingsford
summersworth
Rochester and Southwestern main Berwick
South Berwick and North
Berwick I'm here to oppose this bill as
it allows other state and federally
recognized tribal members to nominate
individuals to this
commission the proposed Bill does not
address other tribal entities that exist
in the state
nor Define what the process would be to
recognize others if this bill were to be
enacted the process today is simple one
application three references and the
governor
approves the desire for state recognized
tribes is one that I absolutely share
however there are better ways to achieve
this goal collaboration conversation
Community then make a recommendation to
the general
court these are the ways that we move
forward towards State recognition
finally for the abanaki people thank you
thank you other questions from the
committee uh my question is um your
tribe is not recognized by the state of
New Hampshire do you currently have the
ability to be on the council um and
would this remove that ability as it's
currently drafted yes ma'am I am
currently working on an application
and my references currently to apply to
the commission okay and then thank you
as a followup if you could re if you
could let me know what specifically
would be needed in order to preserve
your access to serving on the council
while recognizing all of the challenges
around recognition I'd greatly
appreciate that yes ma'am thank
you any seeing no further questions
thank you very much um next I'll call
hi my thank you for allowing me to speak
today my name name is Melinda Sims and
I'm speaking in opposition to HB
161 um thank you for this opportunity I
stand in strong opposition to House Bill
161 as it undermines New Hampshire's
governmental Authority and creates an
unprecedented transfer of power to outof
State entities this bill removes the
governor's appointment appointment
Authority a fundamental executive
function recognized by the New Hampshire
Constitution and instead empowers the
Speaker of the House along with tribal
Chiefs many from Vermont to control
membership of a New Hampshire State
commission the proposed legislation
specifies that Vermont abanaki tribes
and other New England tribes can
nominate commission members according to
the National Conference of State
legislatures no other state allows
external entities from different states
to control membership of their
government bodies this creates a
dangerous precedence where New
Hampshire's governmental Affairs become
subject to outside influence furthermore
the New Hampshire Supreme Court has
consistently held that state commissions
must remain accountable to New
Hampshire's elected officials to ensure
proper oversight and represent ation of
our citizens interests the proposed
structure eliminates this essential
checks and
balances the current commission
structure while not perfect maintains
proper accountability to New Hampshire's
governance system while still ensuring
Native American
representation if reforms are needed
they should preserve New Hampshire's
sovereignity
rather than seeding control to external
entities I urge this committee to reject
hb1 161 and protect New Hampshire's
constitutional authority to govern its
own commissions the basic principles
that New Hampshire government B should
be accountable to New Hampshire elected
officials is not a partisan issue it's a
foundation
governance principle that transcends
political
divides thank you thank you uh
representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair so I'm
wondering uh are you a member of the
commission on Native American Affairs
that already exists here in New
Hampshire yes I'm you you're a current
member yes sir are you here on behalf of
the commission or are there other
members of the commission who are I'm
here on my own
behalf I follow up yes follow up so are
you aware of whether the commission is
aware that that this bill is being heard
today we have somebody else from the
commission what we have somebody else to
speak I'm asking her whether she knows I
have a card yes can I ask her for an
answer I'll allow you to continue with
that but when we have the cards and we
know who's already speaking we we don't
need to ask them okay h defer my
question for the moment thank you since
you kind of have answered it thank you
thank you yes representative
SL uh thank you why in your opinion are
there five open seats on the
commission well they uh were in
transition and getting um members on
board
so I mean just like any other committee
there's always open seats and so they're
they're going through the process of of
uh interviewing people and getting them
on board now I know in the past it's
been kind of
challenging um getting people on because
it takes so many months to get it
through the system to be approved so uh
when you've got five seats and it's
taking three to four months a piece it
takes a little bit of time but I do know
that there are people that have applied
and and uh they're going through that
process thank you followup and just to
clarify these are Rec recent vacancies
then that I think you would need to ask
uh the PE the uh Chief and others on
that board thank you thank you thank you
representative D thank you madam chair
so I remain confused um which is not
unusual the my question has to do with
is your opposition
related to the fact that it's somebody
who doesn't reside in New Hampshire
who's making the nominations and the
reason that I'm what I'm trying to wrap
my head around is I could understand the
opposition well I could understand
hopefully a lot of things but I I would
understand if the opposition were to say
for example the governor of Vermont
making a
nomination but where the nomination is
coming from that I believe it says in
here but I um nominated by the chiefs of
of the state recognized abanaki or
federally recognized tribes the
nominations would be coming from the
tribes just perhaps by people that don't
live they don't reside in New Hampshire
but the people who are nominated do
reside in New Hampshire can you clarify
for me do you understand what I'm I'm
not very articulate do you understand
what I'm saying which is I could
understand if it were like coming from
the uh the governor of Vermont as
opposed to um the the tribal Chief in
Vermont who also possibly represents
people of the same Indian tribe in New
Hampshire as well because of that
historic relationship thank you Sor let
me see if I'm understanding your your
question correctly are you asking me why
as a Native American I am not allowing
another Native American tribe in on on
here from from Vermont or or no no no my
goodness okay I'm sorry oh I I think I
think was the question that you think
that it is um a lack of accountability
to the people of New Hampshire to have
somebody who is not from New Hampshire
making nominations to the commission is
that way you were asking her it's sort
sort of sort of what what I'm trying to
understand what the objection is and I
I'm not suggesting it's a lack of
accountability or what the concern is
but is it is it that there somebody who
is residing outside of New Hampshire who
is making that nomination even if
nominally representing people who live
in New Hampshire Hampshire but we are
not recognizing but Vermont is thank you
for your question I can only speak for
myself
personally um I don't want someone from
another state coming in and telling me
how to um live in this state and so I
have that objection but I also have
other
objections um there is a question as to
the
genealogy um the question I have
personally is it the person that States
they're a genealogist are they an
actually certified genealogist through
the board of
genealogy um or were they just made that
position because they have a degree or
knowledge of History so what is their
actual certification so I have a lot of
questions and until those are answered I
I kind
accept someone coming in and from
another state and then trying to take
over
and that's thank you thank you other
questions from the committee I do have
oh representative
Bailey I I guess I'm somewhat confused
too um we've heard that this uh a tribal
group that
had historically was in Vermont New
Hampshire and we've heard this morning
even into Maine
and there seems to be Vermont
recognition and an overall Federal
recognition but New Hampshire seems to
be missing and evidently Maine is
missing too um is this intended to
supply the New Hampshire piece um thank
you I think that is sort of where this
is looking to head I I do have to say
that as somebody who um ancestor sent
her daughter to go hide in the bushes
when they were coming around to do a
headcount and and list people for the
registry after being marched from the
Carolinas to Oklahoma um I have
sensitivity to the genealogy and all the
details that go in with Indian law
because I'm not I can't qualify as a
member of the tribe because of that um
and I recognize how complex this is I'm
really thankful to get all of these
details about specific challenges and
I'm hopeful that we'll be able to
continue the dialogue if this is
something that moves forward so that we
can understand the way to do it
correctly because it is so complex
between federal law um tribe tradition
and then law for the recognition I think
the abanaki are in a really difficult
position because they are recognized by
Vermont and those who don't have family
ties to Vermont can't be recognized so
therefore they can't sell the
abanaki um crafts so this it's something
that I think we need to figure out how
to deal with but we need to make sure we
don't make things worse in the process
is that a good understanding of the
challenges we're facing it is a very
good understanding but there is another
part of the puzzle is there's a a
question as to the genealogy and the
authenticity of Vermont and so odino has
come in and
they're they've been doing a a large
study and they've gone to um the United
Nations about it and and so on so
there's a lot of parts this puzzle that
need to be looked at first before
someone just comes in and takes over a
board
so so my my description was just simply
scratching the surface so this is
complex and deep so thank you thank
there's no other questions from the
committee I appreciate your testimony
thank you thank you uh next I'll call
Sher poran I apologize that I probably
have not said your name correctly that's
okay I've had three and all three have
been
um badly pronounced it's per
I had trouble telling which letters were
which so per up yeah handwriting is
atrocious to it's not as bad as mine but
thank
[Laughter]
you okay my name is Sher perau I'm an
abanaki I belong to the kak tribe which
is unate recognized um I also have been
on the board I'm working on my fourth
year and
um I we have fashioned a letter which
will be passed around that I'm going to
read to you and then I can probably
answer any questions and I have one or
two of my
own to the members of the executive
department of the administration
committee reason HB 161 2025 titled
changing the membership of the New
Hampshire Commission on Native American
Affairs at at at is January 13 2025
meeting the New Hampshire Commission on
Native American Affairs consulted about
the proposed hb1 161
discussed its ramifications for the
Native American people of many tribes in
addition to the
abanaki who are residents of New
Hampshire at the conclusion of this
consultation and by unanimous roll call
vote the New Hampshire Commission on
Native American Affairs decided to
request that this committee not pass HB
616 hb1 161 as currently written due to
the following
reasons one New Hampshire commit
on Native American Affairs is very
concerned that for three consecutive
years now legislation regarding or
mentioning the New Hampshire Commission
on the Native American Affairs has been
proposed to the legisl New Hampshire
legislature without the authors of this
bill ever having consulted with the
commission or even having notified the
commission that the bill a bill that
would impact the abanaki and other
Native American residents of New
Hampshire was being written it is
troubling that the commission has been
and continues to be marginalized in This
Way New Hampshire has a relatively small
Native American population however we
are certain that New Hampshire
government agrees that the specialized
needs of its Native American residents
are unique and must be addressed at
present New Hampshire has no federally
or state recognized tribes or chiefs
therefore the commission was created to
advocate for and heighten the public
awareness of the abanaki and other
Native American residents of our of New
Hampshire however if
HB 161 is passed as written New
Hampshire indigenous reg residents will
have no choice no voice or
representation in their state home the
language of hb1 161 as proposed
relinquishes decision-making regarding
New Hampshire Native American residents
to outof State federally recognized or
state tribes thus removing oversight of
Hampshire three hb1 161 removes the New
Hampshire Commission of Native American
Affairs who are New Hampshire government
appointees representing the New
Hampshire Department of Natural and
cultural resources New Hampshire
Department of Transportation New
Hampshire State Council on the Arts the
New Hampshire division vision of travel
and tourism with their specialized
knowledge each of these appointees
brings a unique perspective and skill
set as well as the support of their
departments to the work of the
commission HB number four is HB 161
removes from the New Hampshire
Commission on Native American Affairs
its process of the governor's
appointment of the recommendation of its
qualified indigenous members at large
hb1 161 also removes the commission
Administration administrative attachment
to the oversight from the New Hampshire
Department of Natural and cultural
resources with its specialized knowledge
based that the Germain to the support of
the commission work instead hb1 161
assigns that oversight to the New
Hampshire Speaker of the House who with
all due respect likely has little to no
specialized knowledge of the history
culture and current needs of the new
Hamp
contemporary Native American resident
and two May other and two May other
responsibilities to take on this
assignment five furthermore hb1 161
proposes action and oversight that the
are associated with the federal law such
as the Native American Graves protection
act rep representation act the Indian
Child Welfare Act and the Indians arts
and crafts Act these laws are federal
and do not fall under the state
commission jurisdiction as implied in
the current wording of the hb1 161 we
have additional concerns about the
wording of the hb1 161 and the ways in
which this bill Pro processes to the
restructure of the New Hampshire
Commission on the native Affair American
Affairs however the issue enumerates in
this statement that there the enumerates
in this statement are the ones we see to
be the most pressing we ask that the
committee find this bill expedient in
expedient to legislation respectfully
submitted by me on behalf of the
commission of Native American
Affairs
um any questions thank you
representative de and then
representative SL thank you so much
Madam chair um are there members of the
commission today who under this propos
proposed legislation if it passed would
no longer be eligible to be members of
the commission yes and could you explain
all the Reas not part of a recognized
federally or state tribe we have many
members we have many people in New
Hampshire that are not part of a
recognized tribe we do not have state
recognition we do not have Federal
recognition and anybody who lives in the
state who is federally recognized is
more than welcome to apply and sit on
the board we are not restricting fed
recognized matter of fact I think we
have
one Christine isn't she I don't know we
have uh um a lady from the Midwest who
lives here and she is on there and I
believe she's Navajo I believe I'm not
really I don't really care you show up
it's a
person anyways and I'm and she's she
grew up on a reservation so we do have a
federally recognized person um
I think she's the only one maybe maybe
one or two more but the thing is is
that we our biggest frustration I asked
to be on this commission to help find
the indigenous people recognition Okay
to Aid in our culture to Aid in teaching
just to be recognized that we are here
and I have spent the last three years
dealing with this and not even being
able to have time because we are
volunteers we travel some of us travel
two to three hours to sit we finally
have gotten uh the the ability to have
half you know somebody lives too far
away or a sick child or whatever to be
able to video in but that took us two
and a half years to do that we are
running against legislation to stop us
from doing what we need to do if
somebody lives in New Hamp Hampshire who
is federally recognized tribe that lives
in you know as long as they live in New
Hampshire they can be in any tribe they
want even you know Puerto Rico we can
they can be on the on the tribe on the
commission sorry followup thank you very
much Madam chair does the the way that
it's written currently and the current
constitution of the commission however
does that leave people out who reside in
New Hampshire who are members of the
abanaki tribe from applying currently to
be on the commission by the governor's
appointment right they have to go
through the governor they need a letter
of recommendation from their Chief or
from an indigenous Chief person three
letters of recommendation and one
Written Letter and it's submitted to the
governor now our last Governor was way
slow in responding to those things uh
from my information which is hearsay so
don't put it gospel we have people that
have signed up and asked and have sent
in all their requirements but have not
been approved or
unapproved thank
you very fast thank you so so there's
nobody what I'm hearing is that there's
nobody who's part of the AV and I can
tribe or the there's nobody in New
Hampshire under the current system who
is ex who is being excluded from service
correct is that correct okay corre thank
you so much correct I think the only
exclusion is maybe you're in jail I
don't know you know but even then it um
it I don't think it has anything to do
with with um recognition it's all to do
with what you want to do and support
thank you for your patience you're
welcome representative
Lae yeah I I wanted to give you an
opportunity to answer my previous
question which was um why why are there
five vacancies in your opinion um
because there are um we have no control
over who gets approved and who doesn't
that all goes to the governor and right
now we have a brand new governor and she
is probably so swamped she doesn't even
know the color of her toenail polish so
we need to you know bear with her but we
have had five openings I know for a fact
two people have applied and have not
heard anything for over a year um you
know one way or the other so it's it's a
process that needs to be maybe sped up a
little bit and brought to light but it's
also the wheels turn slowly um we have
been you know up until we could do uh
the video conferencing and vote we had
to have 12 representatives there and
often times we would have 11 and the
12th one would have a flat tire and we
would have to
cancel that it was our biggest stumbling
block we cannot I mean the uh 2024 we
had one meeting and the only reason we
got that meeting in between between
sickness and snowstorms and every
everything else availability we only
able to get that one meeting in because
of that and we got it in and we were
voted so that we had to get all 12
members together to vote that we would
accept and we could have video
conferencing you know those things
really hold us up and we were the only
commission that I know of that had to
that couldn't do this or that couldn't
have had to have all 12 members you know
we had a minimum of 12 and guess how
many members we had 12 so thank you I I
think we get the the problem of no
that's all right we we've dealt with
this with a lot of other commissions as
well so we're sensitive to that
representative sellers thank you madam
chair just out of curiosity it does say
the word Chiefs plural in here how many
chiefs are there in the tribe it's just
one tribe right um our I I don't know
about other tribes um our tribe we have
um the main Chief we have a subchief and
we have a war
chief um they are you know each have
their own individual jobs and things
like that but um Chief is more of a a
leader okay thank you uh seeing no other
questions from the committee thank you
very much and thank you for your service
on the commission uh next I'll call Paul
Ka needle Denise pulio sagasa Paul pulio
sag kaak Pak people
kakipi Hello friends my name is Denise
pulio I'm the head female speaker and
this is Paul pulio head male speaker and
chief of the kak band of the Penacook
abnaki people we come to you today from
our ancient Penacook Village called
odinak kuppi which translates to the
Village of the narrowing Waters now
Hampshire we thank you uh to be here
Madame chairman and uh distinguished uh
Representatives we have a uh a letter
that we're going to hand out um
reflecting what's going on here today um
I also was one of the founding members
of the Commission in 2010 I was on there
briefly um over time
I should probably pipe up I did serve on
the commission for six years um five of
them were as Vice chair um and I just
rotated off about a year ago hence one
of the vacant seats and for all Clarity
I am now the chair of the commission I
was uh and as uh you've heard the
nomination process and the selection
process is very lengthy I put my name in
almost a year in advance uh and it took
and I love Chris anunu but it took
forever to get through before I got
finally nominated and put in place and
uh during our last meeting which was
very successful which we had a meeting
yesterday I sat as the chair for the
first time presiding over the uh
commission commission went very well it
was well received we had public there
and we had full
representation I see that uh our
director of the Department of cultural
and natural and cultural resources are
here I've asked him to be here to
explain the nomination process and how
the selection process because this has
been out in the air in a lot of rumors
that there was a nominating committee
within the commission this was true when
representative G was a chair but that
was eliminated and the process was
strictly through the proper channels of
legislation and those letters would be
directed to Ben Wilson who is in the
audience today who can explain this and
they were vetted and looked at and you
know selected to be going forward to the
governor we had no control over this I
had no control over my appointment
either until I went into Chris and said
we're we're running short we need to get
some of these appointments through so
you're all aware of the commission you
know appointment process
problems what's more interesting to us
is the way this was worded in a specific
specific
ways you know you heard a lot about
title 25
law we're talking about neight here with
title 25 law our tribe uh filed for
federal acknowledgment in
1995 and in spite of the fact that
vermonts keep on saying we never filed
for a petition we are 151 on the federal
Bia list there's over 600 tribes there
very difficult to find who's applied but
we applied at the same time that the
missc group in Vermont applied they went
through the process enforced the federal
recognition and were denied and they
went on an appeal and got denied again
it's two strikes are out in the federal
system also there's a misconception
about State versus uh Federal recognized
tribes versus title 25 tribes when you
petition the federal government you put
your foot in the door and you're
protected under a clause called
self-determination
it's well in the documents that tribes
and communities can go under the
self-declared Avenue because only
legislature the federal legislature can
actually create or deny a tribe its
status and that process is quite
lengthy what I'm trying to get at is
here we are
protected we have been working with the
federal government since 1990 in a lot
of capacity including the state which
seems to be totally ignored by this
legislature we've been actively a
community leader in this area for a long
time and we're participating in the best
we can but when we read this bill as
it's
written it seems to like it tears into
the heart of the
issue they really never liked the fact
that it was a diverse group when I was
on the commission from the begin could
you please not make accusations about
people's uh Viewpoint or any of that
and just if you talk about the specific
basics of it I think we have a pretty
good understanding of some of the
challenges the challenges are that why
would we give up State sovereignty to
allow any other entity no matter what it
is any commission you just label any way
you want why would you go to some other
agency National or Regional to get your
appointments filled that that's a
strictly a very serious issue with the
state we a live three here die and you
know everybody has a right of
representation I'd like to see the
commission represent all the indigenous
population the state not just abnaki it
was never the intent in 2010 that this
was an abnaki organization This was
meant to represent everybody we have
Hawaiians we have alaskans here we can't
force people to join the commission but
we don't deny them either we've never
Divi Divi you know denied them but when
you read these these Clauses that are
written here what line is it um so the
bill the bill um immediately starts off
by limiting the commission from a
current 15 member seat to seven members
um the bill also removes art tourism and
um the department of cultural resources
from the bill which also then in turn
removes All State oversight over the
commission it also limits the
commission's ability to access programs
and um other functions that are
available through um the state um uh
agencies um the membership um by naming
only state or federally recognized
tribes as naming um uh members on the
commission actually violates title 25
and it actually um violates our legal
rights as a petitioning tribe um passage
of this bill would um make it make it
possible that we could sue the state for
lack of
representation um the bill um removes
the layers of vetting through the
department of cultural and natural
resources as well as the governor's
office it removes the Governor from
making the
appointments um and I actually had a
question are there any other Commissions
in the state where the house Speaker
makes the appointments and bypasses the
governor because I was unable to find
one but hopefully someone here would be
able to correct me on that but that's
besides the point if you continue on the
bill bill um uh the
um I think you have a really good amount
that's laid out and in this written
testimony that wasn't even half of it
I'm reading from my notes actually if
you wouldn't mind emailing that to the
committee I think that at this point
with the amount of information we need
to keep skimming on the top of the
surface because that's what we're going
to be able to understand all of this
additional supporting information be
very helpful for us all right um I'd be
happy to send um the um acknowledgement
from the federal government for our
Petition of you know for a filing
petition as well and hopefully we can
put that to rest because this is the
third year um we've had to testify on
that and I've supplied evidence um on
the prior two years as well okay thank
you I'd like to wrap up that you know a
lot of these things that were in here
statutory things from uh title 25 those
vermonts already have those rights
ingrained in the fact that they got
State recognition they do not need
subordinate Authority here in New
Hampshire to do their arts and crafts
that's protected because they are
already a state recognized tribe they
don't need to have a secondary
recognition here their tribal members
that reside here live under that
umbrella same thing for Eagle fevers
child welfare cases we've handled child
welfare cases since the 1990s when the
law came out it's a tribe to government
relationship not a commission the
commission's never vetted for that and I
I in respect to the fact that Ben Wilson
here if there's any questions about the
nomination process he can explain it a
lot better and it takes us out of the
formula because you'll understand it's
it's not complicated it's
straightforward it's just time consuming
thank you there any questions from the
committee representative syes and Men
um I'm something something that occurred
to me that has nothing to do with the
bill but has to do with this situation
and that's if you're not federally or
state recognized how do I know how does
anyone know that you're an abanaki or
that you're a tribe or anything I you
can
just what are your credentials for this
I I think I'll leave that as a
rhetorical question because uh we're
already running significantly behind uh
but thank you it's very challenging
we're happy to answer that for you later
yes if you could if you could fill us in
on what what the questions you think we
asking with the whole committee would
appreciate to hear that um written later
on as a followup representative Schmid
well I certainly hope we're going to
have a subcommittee because we're
getting into all kinds of De details
that are really not appropriate to try
to thrash out in a hearing I thank you I
think the biggest part is we'll try and
understand if this is something where
even a subcommittee could emerge on the
other side with a successful bill or not
but we we will see and see the right
process I think don't think that we'd be
making a vote without having a
subcommittee meeting on this because it
is very complex vote to move it forward
representative loding okay already
handled thank you I I think that if uh
if there's a movement to pass this we
will spend the time in order to dig into
all of these details so thank you very
much thank you very much um in closing I
just want to suggest um uh UNH law does
have an indigenous law professor who's
also a retired Federal um biia judge
which is Bureau of Indian Affairs judge
I would highly suggest that this
committee talks to these to these legal
experts before you pass bills like this
thank you okay thank you thank you next
Stevens thank you for taking my
testimony I'll be very quick I am chief
Don Stevens of the nohan band of the
kusak abanaki nation um a tribe that
happens to be recognized by the state of
Vermont I am here to support our New
Hampshire citizens and I wanted to
explain some of the confusion to kind of
put it in simple terms you all have your
own constituents you represent towns
within your
jurisdiction being a federal state or
non-recognized tribe you are the leader
you are the government and your
responsibility is to support those
constituents underneath you and give
them a voice so we we have citizens I
have over a thousand citizens all over
our Western abanaki territory and
several hundred here in the state of New
Hampshire what we're running into is
that we're here as a government to
support the needs of our citizens just
like you're here to support the needs of
your
constituents what we're asking for in
this bill is to have representation in
New Hampshire in a commission because
that is what you set up as an Avenue to
speak from citizens with Native issues
to the government that is the commission
they're supposed to represent all Native
people they're supposed to support all
the needs and state government right so
that's the Avenue that we have currently
we have had other citizens of ours
supply to the commission who have not
made it on for various reasons so our
voices is not represented so that's like
saying a legislator who represents
Warner and all of a sudden that
legislator is not allowed to be involved
in any policy making decisions that
means that Warner is never going to have
representation their voices are never
going to be heard they're not going to
have their they're not going to support
their constituents so we're not asking
to suppress anybody in New Hampshire
we're not asking to suppress that what
we're asking for is to have a voice
within the state government to represent
our needs and as a chief I have people
from Lincoln Warner
Lancaster um K it um and if I need to
represent all of their needs so if you
have one person that's not speaking to
the tribe how do they know what people
in Lancaster need how do they know what
people in Warner need how do they know
what people in Kentuck it so my role in
our tribal Chief and our
is to communicate with us to say
communicate with us so we can know what
all of those citizens in all those
jurisdictions need so you're
representing our needs in New Hampshire
the best way you can we don't want to
take over New Hampshire it's not our
role we're here to support the longevity
of all the citizens who have been here
who are going to sit on that board no
verm moners are going to sit on the
board all we're doing is saying is that
the right person to represent all of our
people in New Hampshire and we put those
names forward and then whoever decides
um to pick them or not that's up to you
guys that's your government to decide
who could sit on that commission but our
involvement is to say who is the best
person to represent all of our people in
New Hampshire because we are have a
responsibility to all those people um we
had this problem in Vermont with the
commission that there were people that
were on that commission that were either
stonewalling um they wouldn't let other
people be on that commission for
whatever reason um because they felt
threatened or so in 2010 the entire
commission was wiped out and then the
the law was passed to allow every tribe
that's in new hampsh uh Vermont to have
a voice so they could speak for their
people so they were always represented
in state government and state policy so
that is what was trying to be done here
is that we are not excluded and those
hundreds of people that I represent in
New Hampshire have a voice and can speak
right now none of my citizens are on the
commission we've had three applicants
and none of them have got on we have no
voice in New Hampshire so what we have
to do as a government is go around the
commission and work with different state
agencies I have a I have a bison herd in
sted our New Hampshire uh we have we
have a food shelf in Kentuck it we have
maple syrup operations we are in New
Hampshire we are not a state Vermont
state tribe we are a tribe that happens
to be recognized by the state of Vermont
and we do have federal legal agreements
with the Department of interior not for
Bia purposes but we do have agreements
with the the federal government so I'm
here to answer any questions because
I've been involved with this I've been
Chief since 2010 and I'm pretty involved
with all of the political aspects of all
of the people and all the states that we
represent um I'm going to ask a question
before I recognize help it does okay um
given that you represent a ter territory
that doesn't coincide with all the state
boundaries would it violate your
recognition within the state of Vermont
for you to name a a sort of a sub
subtribe or a regional tribe within the
land of New Hampshire and have a chief
that represents those people that reside
within New Hampshire that then would be
able to better serve as a voice and an
Outreach and a and a liaison between
those New Hampshire residents that are
part of your tribe and the count and the
commission well I don't you you are a
tribe
who is recognized like we in Statue we
the nohan band of the kusak abanaki
nation that is our tribal name do can we
can we have representatives in each
state yes that's why you see Sher uh
here Daryl or other people we're not
down here speaking to you they are um
they're the ones that are dealing with
New Hampshire because they are also New
Hampshire citizens I'm here as a support
structure so we could ask someone to be
like if you know
history we were family bands so you had
families that traveled throughout New
Hampshire Vermont Massachusetts
including mine who's tied to the
Phillips Grant up in uh up in the
Northeast Kingdom before Vermont was a
state I mean that that deed is filed in
L in New Hampshire um and our people are
are um tied to that even through our
recognition process in Vermont so the
answer to your question is yes we do
have other people
representing people in that area because
we can't do everything and they live
here they know the the they know
everything that's happening here I'm I'm
two hours away so I work with them so I
hope that answers your question that is
helpful because knowing whether that
would violate your conditions with h
Vermont that's good to know no because
we were recognized by Vermont but each
state is Sovereign and each state can
recognize who they want perfect so and
there are tribes that are recognized
mult mulle States just so people know
it's not a either or there I mean you're
just acknowledging the fact that we're
operating here and we are a tribe here
it's not going to VI that's separate and
Sovereign from Vermont you don't deal
with Vermont politics they don't deal
with yours thank you y uh representative
slot J thank you madam chair um one of
the issues that this bill may have is
that it has a sort of a totalizing
effect on the membership of the board
and one of the issues that the previous
speakers had brought up is that existing
committee members or existing commission
members would be removed uh if these uh
if these new rules took effect and I'm
curious as to whether or not you would
object to instead of all seats being uh
required to be uh members of a
recognized tribe if we gave you five
seats say yeah I have no problem with we
don't want to stifle any voices we don't
want to stifle theirs we don't want to
style any we want a voice so my point
being is whether you amend the bill to
saying okay tribe has a voice on this
commission and you get a seat and then
you submit a bunch of names and whoever
in your committee decides or whoever
decides who those which person or two
that might be that's fine with me um as
long as we have a voice it's that what's
happening right now is we don't have a
voice and since we are a recognized
tribe under the law in statute we want a
voice because this is our traditional
Homeland as well but we're not speaking
for the other tribes we that's up to
them to speak for themselves we don't
want to exclude them we just don't want
to be excluded oursel because somebody
might be mad that we're have people in
Vermont and they're trying to say no
they're Vermont so we're going to reject
their application and then we have no
voice that's what's happening whether
people are saying I have no control of
it or not we are being we had three
applicants none of them were um included
and they had sat on the commission
previously so it's not it's something's
not right and it's broken and we need to
have a voice and that's all I'm asking
thank you followup yes do do you think
that that either denial or delay is a
result of the approval process going
through the governor's office or is
there some other uh I I don't know and I
don't want to speculate but I I have my
own
theories um because they are vacant
seats and and we have three applicants
and none of them were forwarded to the
governor's for for consideration so I
just want to say that um I can't
speculate I'm not going to all I know is
that I'm here to fix a broken process
and just like we did in Vermont is to
have a voice to continue our
Partnerships with the state of New
Hampshire thank you very much
representative Howard thank you for
taking my question uh so under current
law do your tribal members in New
Hampshire already have an opportunity to
serve on this commission if they submit
an application under the current law I
believe there is um anybody I think in
New Hampshire can serve I don't think
it's restricted but the problem is
there's something that's causing a
problem that we're not we're not getting
on the commission and we're not having a
voice but what we did in Vermont is that
because we are a recognized tribe and we
are have citizens in that
constituency we wanted a guaranteed spot
so that way our voice would be heard
because if you just if you don't let our
people on the commission then they're
speaking for our people
without us being involved so that's like
again it's like somebody speaking for
Warner and their and their their
representatives nowhere in the room and
can't be found and that might not be
what Warner wants so people are speaking
for us when we're not at the table so
we're asking for a seat that's all we're
asking for is a seat at the table thank
you thank you representative sers thank
you madam chair so I'm just trying to
understand this a little bit better as
well so be real quick yep you said you
don't have a voice on the commission
here correct at this point does New
Hampshire abanaki have a voice in
Vermont we have no Hampshire people on
our tribe uh tribal board um if you're
asking do they have a voice in the
commission they don't um because there's
no they don't have anybody from Vermont
that's applied for they're not a
recognized tribe so they don't get a
guaranteed seat because the way Vermont
did it is that they guarant because you
were a recognized tribe you had a seat
at the table um but we do there is a
there was a federal uh Native person
that was in on Vermont too because they
are a federally recognized tribe they
have citizens that live there too you
probably have quite a few Federal uh
citizens that might live here um but do
they have a voice um it's a luck of the
draw whether you get on the commission
or not so if this is our Avenue to deal
with New Hampshire government if we
don't have a voice we have to do it
outside of the Avenue news that you guys
created through the commission so that's
why we have to be here and try to fix
this otherwise I'm going to come
straight to you and avoid the commission
because it doesn't speak for me because
it's my responsibility to speak for my
people and if we don't have
representation on the commission then
then the you know that's that's what I'm
saying I have to go outside of that
Avenue so we're just trying to make the
process work so that way if that's the
process that native people have to do is
go through the commission to speak to
the state government then we need a
voice thank you this is actually pretty
helpful because it helps us understand
why they're saying you're going around
and why there's the process we'll try
and figure out what's broken in that
system right so even a simple amendment
to add somebody else that you want to
have there is simple but just give us a
voice thank you thank you very much and
um the last card that I have is for
roaming
wabanaki thank
you I I just want to let everybody know
who's here for house bill for as you're
s taking a seat I'm going to let people
know that for House Bill 470 we should
be able to start that after this and
then we're still delayed with cac1 I
apologize we thought we would catch up
on our time a little bit better because
we had delayed them until 3 o'cl so sir
you if you push the button so the red
light is on oh so it's on okay thank you
um so good afternoon I believe
I'm here on on behalf of myself comments
I'd like to make but also I've been
asked to present a statement from an
Jennison if if the um Madame chair um
agrees if that's the written statement I
think we will read that instead of
having you read that out loud to us okay
thank you so you have that yes thank you
my statement
um I'll get you guys a email a copy so
that you all can have it because I did
bring a ton of them but I'll make sure I
um
okay will gak M
zani and the
louisi Q Q
kette good afternoon everyone my name is
roaming one who roams like a buffalo and
I I'm an unrolled citizen of the abanaki
nation I oppose HB 161 encourage you to
find it inexpedient to
legislate as was
hc7 in
2024 and recognizing alagan band of the
kuak abanaki nation of Vermont here in
New
Hampshire was a very similar attempt to
afford a vermont-based tribe power and
influence over New Hampshire State
policy and
tribes changing the membership of the
New Hampshire Commission on Native
American Affairs why to what and by whom
it is true that New Hampshire sits in
the traditional homeland of the abanaki
people as does
Vermont parts of
Massachusetts and Eastern Canada and the
maritimes but today we're focused on New
Hampshire
the New Hampshire Commission on Native
American Affairs is charged with
recognizing the historic and cultural
contributions of Native Americans to New
Hampshire promoting and strengthening
their own Heritage and furthering their
needs through State policy and programs
HB 161 calls for the commission of seven
members who are residents of the state
in our abanaki or other Native
Americans enrolled in recognized
tribes who will work together to support
the tribes and promote the well-being of
all Native Americans in the
state while this may sound good on first
blush it is
flawed in section in in HD 161 section
3A which discusses the authority to make
commission membership nomination it in
part reads only enrolled tribal citizens
who reside in New Hampshire s shall
be nominated by the Chiefs of the state
recognized
abanaki but there are
none I know you you've heard EOS of this
already
and
um members of the abanaki tribes
recognized by the state of
Vermont which in my opinion is a backd
door way to bring the Vermont nohan into
New Hampshire State Indian Affairs the
spite the first approach last year well
the approach last year with HCR 7 that
failed please do not be fooled by this
veiled attempt of an outsider intrusion
into New Hampshire State and tribal
sovereignty and if you could uh try and
not to give people's
motives yep thank you doing my best
here there are no state recognized
abanaki tribes in New Hampshire that I
know of in fact as I understand it the
commission is charged was charged or
should be charged with helping the state
develop a process to
recognize at least the two and we have
Representatives here of the longstanding
abanaki tribes who have been repeatedly
acknowledged through executive
proclamations the coac traditional band
of The Sovereign abanaki Nation and with
traditional homelands along the the
Connecticut River and central part of
New
Hampshire and with the seat of
government in all stud of New Hampshire
and the kuak band of the Penacook
abanaki people with traditional
homelands encompassing a major portion
of Southeast uh New
Hampshire um in their seat of government
in alter New Hampshire which as you they
mentioned they have a penting uh status
recognition Federal recognition with the
Bia under in DOI
hp61 eliminates the voice of these New
Hampshire based tribes you heard this
which would effectively remove the
current Commission on Native American
Affairs the chair T pulio right there
the secretary Sher right
there and the vice
chair which is their letter here they
would be removed they would be gone they
would have no status no authority to be
on the this
commission um furthermore it takes the
Sovereign power and right of the State
of New Hampshire to appoint it members
to its own commission on Native American
Affairs and turns it over in part to a
Vermont base band of the abanaki who
have repeatedly demonstrated and I'm
sorry to say this they are not friends
of the New Hampshire could you could you
summarize because you will be sending
I think in
um there are in
fact many abanaki people here in two
wellestablished tribes abanaki right
here who are willing and currently
serving the people and the native people
of the of the state and are open to the
commission the remedy that I heard here
in I even heard it from Chief Stevens to
have a place at least one place on the
commission for other tribes like in New
Hampshire like the nohan and let's not
forget there are three others the
misisco the elu and the K act there why
not have all of the abanaki people
tribes that are established have a place
in the New Hampshire commission that's a
remedy that's a great remedy but let's
also see Chief step even stand up and
fight for that same ability in Vermont
it may not be the policy now but as we
know laws are here and they can be
changed so that should happen as well
because I can assure you just like Chief
Stevens has people here in in New
Hampshire Chief
pulet and chief Paul from the New
Hampshire bands have people in Vermont
there's no doubt about that so anyways
um
I I will end here and I ask again that
you find HB 161 the way it is expedient
to legislate William me T GC thank you
all and all of our relations we
appreciate your support to secure and
protect New Hampshire tribal and state
sovereignty roing Buffalo of the
wabanaki and proud citizen of the
abanaki
nation thank you very much um are there
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much um it's probably pretty likely it
will end up in one of the subcommittees
we'll see if uh we just continue sending
everything that's not pensions and
Licensing to yours or if we figure out a
better way to distribute it um with our
time but thank you all um any further
work on this bill will be noticed um and
we hope to have everyone's involvement
in that even if you can't travel the
full distance uh providing more
information for us and feedback is
always helpful so thank you all for your
time and with that I'm closing the
hearing on House Bill 161 um I'm looking
to text the prime sponsor of House Bill
470 because he's an executive session
but my other question would be if it
makes sense for us to jump to cicr one
do we have only two people that we will
be testifying on cic1 which we've
already delayed from 11 o'clock until
3 can somebody text representative
Moffett he's sitting right back here is
he oh good yes ah there you are yes um I
think we'll go with cic1 um I think that
are we going to have representative moss
and fos is there anybody else who will
be here to speak for
cac1 okay so with that I will open the
hearing on cac1 we will be holding uh HB
470 immediately following and I
recognize representative mof at the
prime sponsor Madam
chair people yes yes it's not quite 3 o
oh it's not quite three so I shall not
do that quite yet um actually before I
do that let me consult with the actual
chair of this committee to make sure
that I'm not making a big old hash out
of
everything yes start late but not early
okay perfect then um when the clock
strikes three I will start on cacr and
then I will move to House Bill 470 and I
I think I see three people who will be
testifying on that one once we're
here
so
welcome back I'm opening the hearing on
cac1 and I call the prime sponsor
representative
maof thank you madam chair uh again for
the record I am state representative
Mike Moffett representing
District 4 in marac the beautiful towns
of canterberry and
Lowden and uh we're back with cacr one
which uh is not the first time we've
been here uh not everybody who was here
this morning is able to return I see a
couple of State reps are back and I'm uh
grateful for that I know secretary of
state scanland was here ready to to uh
uh attend this morning and I don't think
he's was able to come
back excuse me so I just passed out a
copy of a recent New Hampshire Journal
iCal piece on this subject uh cac1 which
is a measure establishing a lieutenant
governor position for New
Hampshire and among the things uh that I
the response to this uh article this uh
opinion piece which I just passed out
was was very very positive uh among
other things I was invited to appear in
a radio network uh to talk about cac1
there was some genuine um excitement
about the potential this measure has uh
and yesterday I emailed uh yall uh in
this committee the a link to the uh it's
a fairly short radio uh uh Network
interview on this that uh could maybe
complement a little bit what you'll hear
briefly
here so um I do I do want to point out
that this bill does have bipartisan
support uh I'm the only sponsor listed
because of dealing uh with the new
fangled portal
process uh this has had multiple
sponsors in the past and and one of the
former sponsors is is here right now uh
so uh while I'm listed as the only
sponsor that's uh partly a function of
me in the timeline in the new portal
process we will take the support of the
people that are willing to say they are
supporting it for granted thank you
madam chair um yes so it's not just me
uh So currently at least 43 states have
Lieutenant Governors now I know that's
not a reason for us to do that we're New
Hampshire uh but there is a strong case
for looking at uh what we have in place
and how we can do it better uh in doing
it the New Hampshire way so we presently
have uh an extra constitutional
gubernatorial line of succession a lot
of you have been here before you've
heard me and others bring this up before
uh and it's a problem it it's
potentially a big problem it's extra
constitutional I'm a Civic guy I'm I'm
the guy who pushes the Civics bills
forward and uh and this in the problem
some of you already know if you've had a
chance to look at some of the material
that has been pushed out
previously um the Senate President the
state Senate President is the person who
replaces the governor in terms of line
of succession it's been that way yes for
a long time uh this has most recently
happened in 2016 when Senate President
Chuck moris uh replaced Maggie Hassen
for governor Maggie Hassen briefly when
uh she was sworn in as a US
senator uh that's happened earlier uh
Ralph how from Lebanon was Senate
President he replaced Jud Greg briefly
uh when uh Governor Greg became Senator
Greg in
1992 but Ponder what happened in
1982 when Senate President Vestor Roy
our first female governor actually uh
she was sworn in as acting Governor or
as Governor uh after the death of uh
Democrat ug
Gallen uh who died a after the election
he was the incumbent Governor he was the
governor he passed away and and Vester
Roy Senate President was uh sworn in to
replace him uh they were of different
parties and that's part of the problem
part of the issue here assume gallon had
won that election in
1982 uh and then passed away uh he'd
have been replaced by somebody from a
different party that's just
problematical
so we
simply cannot and should not have the
same person leading both the executive
branch and the Executive Branch the uh
the Senate President as you all know uh
is ah head of the legislative bran
Senate President so to have the head of
the legislative branch become the head
of the Executive Branch is just
fundamentally extra constitu there are
all kinds of problems with that and um
we we'll touch on them real
quick so Morris and how and Roy did not
resigned their jobs as Senate President
when they became when they were sworn in
as Governor but all three of those cases
were for very short periods of time and
their tenures of office as chief chief
executive uh were very limited but what
if a Senate President needed to serve
several months uh as chief executive uh
I don't think Secretary of State SC is
not here like I said he was here this
morning he and I looked into this to
confirm the U the succession
arrangements and what we learned uh and
confirmed in statute present in the
present Constitution is that if a
governor died or left office in his his
or her first year uh they they would
make an arrangement for a special
election if it happened in his second
year or her second year uh then the
Senate President would become acting
governor for the whole year or or most
of the year and so that raises all kinds
of really serious questions now we've
been lucky I've been here before and
people have said we've been fine for 200
years you know we don't need a
lieutenant governor we it works
perfectly well it it doesn't it hasn't
uh as an exam I know the committee
report the last time around uh I went
back and checked it and it said uh our
system works perfectly well consider
what happened uh some of you remember
Secretary of State Gardner speaking of
Secretary of States who I've also spoken
to about this uh he shared that when he
was a new secretary of state which is a
long time ago uh in terms of line of
succession the leaders of the state were
out of state he was became acting
Governor so while he was acting Governor
he signed some uh paperwork he signed
this he signed that he swore in a
judge uh is acting governor and come to
find out uh at the time Bill was uh in
his 20s he wasn't 30 years old yet so of
course you know folks pouned and said
all right the judge is illegitimate he
was sworn in by someone who was
unqualified by con the Constitution to
be the governor so no it hasn't worked
perfectly uh it's honestly straight talk
it's the worst succession uh chief
executive
session uh plan in the country in in
many of our views by
far so part of what would have what
would have happened if Governor sonono
God forbid had been struck by lightning
in say n uh 2020 uh Donna Susi was the
Pres Senate President and so uh Senator
suusi would have become the governor to
finish out sununu's
term and what would she have done would
she have the government has like 15 or
so employees or on his staff would uh
Governor Susi have kept uh Governor
sonuna staff in place uh could she work
with his people does she fire them all
uh we've been lucky that didn't happen
uh but it could and we need to to to
think about that the reverse was true in
2011 20 some of you will remember uh
Governor Lynch his last term
uh was uh the was dealing with a
legislature in which his party was the
minority in fact I met uh yesterday I
saw Peter bragon who's the former uh
Senate President president at that time
in fact I asked him to come in and and
and uh sit in on this I don't Peter
wasn't able to make it but had something
happened to Lynch a Democrat uh Peter
bragon Republican would have become
governor that's not how the people voted
it's a terrible situation and uh again
we we've been very
lucky so perhaps if a senate president
became Governor they'd resign who knows
uh but if they did resign to so that
they didn't lead two branches at the
same time which is utterly
extra-constitutional
uh if they did resign as Senate
President then that disenfranchises you
know 5% of uh the the
voters uh if they didn't or or if they
kept their seat as these other Senators
did for short periods of time uh there's
all kinds of potential for for conflict
in fact the potentially someone could
Donna suusi or Peter bragon could have
uh sponsored a measure in the
legislative branch and then became chief
executive and signed it is in the
executive branch it's uh it really is is
is crazy so I I mentioned I did meet
with Secretary of State scandin on this
we looked at the succession arrangements
and they've already address that and
this is a problem that just doesn't
happen in other states so uh those of us
who who care about uh a constitutional
succession plan uh have have come up
originally a couple of people who were
sponsors are now in the state senate and
and they actually I won't take credit
for this had the idea of doing something
the New Hampshire way having a citizen
Lieutenant government just like we are
all citizen legislators pay him the same
as the Senate President $125 a year
which I've offered to pay as I did the
last time we came we went through this
so this could be a wonderful example of
improving government in the best way
essentially doubling
our gubernatorial Manpower at no cost
two Governors for the price of one and
that's not I don't we don't see that as
bigger government we see that as better
government the New Hampshire way um our
governor as you can imagine gets
countless more invit they have a
full-time scheduler they get countless
more invitations for this or that or
this or that than they can possibly
respond to building dedications ribbon
cting testimonials funerals School
visits on and on a lieutenant governor
could
the the capacity of the chief executive
to do twice as
much the line of succession would be
cleaner New Hampshire voters would now
vote for a ticket and be assured that
the state would avoid the chaos I
described that we've been generally
lucky to avoid mostly uh if the sen
especially if the Senate presidents of a
different party so again the sucession
issue addressed by the cacr is
nonpartisan there's no way to know which
part is going to control which branches
in the future it's a very nonpartisan
bipartisan measure it's just put in by
people who want us to do government in
the best
way um in earlier cacr and this topic
did not move forward as I mentioned uh
committee reports said we had a perfect
system just just utterly disagree we've
been as I said we've been lucky I talked
about Bill Gardner um and I have reached
out to every former Governor regarding
the cacr every living governor former
Governor uh one of the responses I did
get back from a former Governor involved
a concern that the lieutenant governor
might not get along with the governor
because they they saw some other states
lieutenant governor would fight with the
governor uh but in every State's
different for as I said 43 states have
Lieutenant Governors but sometimes
they're elected separately and that's
where there were some problems our
proposal is to have them run a as a
ticket as a team uh so that there would
be a team in the primary whichever
ticket won the Primary would go on to
the general election so there you have
it
um the questions last time around there
were I do want to touch on this too
before I before I
close questions that came up last time
where will the desk be uh who's going to
pay for the business cards are they
going to get a phone uh all good
questions I used to teach Noti such this
thing as a bad question uh and the
answer my answer is that the Governors
would Define the roles of their
lieutenants that's kind of how
presidents work with vice presidents and
and that's that's basically what
happened uh we would want to be clear
that
the uh lieutenant governor would be paid
$125 a year same as the Senate President
and I'll tell you that I did some
research the governor's office budget
right now is 2,1
140,000 $39 for fy2 according to the
latest hb1 budget so the governor can
manage that budget and find the business
card money in that budget that they
already have they they so we don't want
to see any extra money whatsoever uh go
to putting in a lieutenant governor so
and I I keep paring we've been fine
forever we've never done that before we
don't want to grow government uh
hopefully I've made that clear this will
cost nothing extra as we propos it and
yet we get two Governors for No Ex to to
do twice as much good work for New
Hampshire make the lieutenant Governor a
housing Zar or make the lieutenant
governor a trade Ambassador there's so
much that could be done and it no extra
extra cost so we see it as a win-win-win
better government fixes the extra
constitutional problem doubles the
person power uh and uh as I look around
this room I do see a whole bunch of
potential future Lieutenant Governors I
really do um and I'll I'll stop there
and I'd be happy to take questions if if
are there represent representative sloty
and representative men
Howard yes thank you um in in this model
do you envision the lieutenant governor
uh I'm I'm imagining the federal vice
president serves as the president of the
Senate is there any Lieutenant governors
of other states that you're aware of who
serve in similar roles think of the
question in terms of other states having
a similar model to what we propose here
is that kind of what you're I more so
that the the federal model is how I
imagine these things work and it's
probably May is likely that not the
model that's used in the states in the
various States the it's my understanding
that the vice president serves as the
president of the Senate is that corre
the terminology is that similar to how
the states operate and it it doesn't
appear to be what the model that you're
offering here right it's really
fascinating with our federal system to
look at what other states do uh some uh
Lieutenant Governors are automatically
Senate presidents it varies in fact one
of the speakers that's going to follow
me fellow State represent actually some
research into that type of thing and I
think she'll touch on some of that uh
and again the as I said earlier the
actual roles of and assignments given to
the lieutenant governor by the governor
If This Were Ever to move forward would
we see it as at the discretion of the
governor uh What uh you know some
presidents make their vice president uh
you know a
borders are or whatever uh so as I said
earlier if the governor were this to
move forward if the governor wanted to
uh
assign certain duties such as as I
mentioned before a how put them in in
charge of a of a Housing Initiative or
have them oversee that type of thing or
trade for example uh but uh I I think
one of the following speakers will touch
a little bit better on what what you uh
asked okay representative Howard thank
you for taking my question so I
understand that you uh mentioned that
the lieutenant governor would be running
as a ticket alongside the governor and
that would be selected during the
primary process yes would you be willing
to uh allow parties to potentially uh
nominate a uh lieutenant governor after
the primary thank you for the question
uh interesting question the way we
envision this and the way the wording is
in the proposed uh cacr is that the
there would be a team a ticket uh that
would be uh on the ballot for the
primary uh as to whether and I I I see
where your thought process is going if
uh if after the primary there was some
folks who wanted to see a different
ticket if that could happen uh that's
something I you you because you own this
measure now you you could look at
rewarding that uh but presently the way
we initially uh submitted this uh the
ticket is in place during the primary
season uh but like I said I I know I
know what you're thinking and u i i very
interesting I understand the sentiment
to maybe what if somebody like one
person from each of two different
tickets could they combine them uh
that's something that's not part of this
current cacr thank you yes but I believe
current election law if there isn't
someone on the ticket allows the party
to fill
it this yeah I'm getting a hearing next
week uh Madam chair so oh
sorry anyway I it's my P my
understanding is if there is a vacancy
on the ticket after the primary the
party can can choose to fill it right uh
uh sec I'm not an expert uh secretary
scandin isn't here unfortunately uh he
was uh I've talked to him several he was
here this morning uh not that he was
going to take a position on it but uh
you know the question that just came up
as Secretary of State and I as I said I
Al also talked to Bill Gardner uh the
Secretary of State could better uh
address that type of scenario and I also
point out uh as with all of our you know
I'm a committee chair I understand the
committee's own these now uh depending
point you do with this uh you certainly
can U look at some different language is
I reread it today uh it wasn't clear in
the current language about the
$125 uh payment which our intent when we
went to OS before and this time was to
be clear that they would be lieutenant
governor would be paid the same as the
Senate President and that wording isn't
as clear uh out of os as I would have
liked that to be that's another piece
you could possibly look at if you wanted
to to make sure it's clear uh what the
compensation would be okay thank you
other questions thank you representative
Schultz thank you madam chair and
members of Edna good to see some friends
I served on this committee for four
years not most of you weren't on the
committee at the time but it's good to
see yall um and I will say
representative Moffett was correct uh
when the Porto was introduced his bill
was early
I saw the button and it just said on the
front page that I should have clicked
through if you want to opt out of any
legislation click here if you'd clicked
there as I later learned you could also
agree to be on a Bill had I known that I
would have clicked through at early um
and forly been a co-sponsor of this bill
again um and I and I think it's a great
idea uh as it happens I've worked in uh
nine other states before New Hampshire
including where I grew up Kentucky I
worked for the lieutenant governor of
Kentucky when he was running for US
Senate he did not win um but it was a
wonderful experience I I watched as the
governor uh of that time was running for
office and the process as it happened
when he chose Steve Henry to be his
lieutenant governor and it was really
exciting obviously they have a St St
they even have a place to live I mean
it's this is the new H the bill the way
it's written is how we would do it in
New
Hampshire uh to me uh and I think it's
the fairest way to do it not a lot of
money like almost zero dollar um I like
the idea of a citizen lieutenant
governor um and uh just to address a
couple quick points that were asked um I
don't remember exactly how it's written
in the bill but if if you want the
lieutenant governor to serve as a
tiebreaker the way our vice president is
not a bad idea you know we have 24 state
senators which leads to one of my
biggest reasons that I support this um
if a Senate President uh becomes
Governor especially for a long time uh
that means they've only been elected by
23 or less people you know maybe only
50% plus one of the chamber so 13 people
you know versus uh the choice of a
lieutenant governor to be on a ticket
with a gubernatorial candidate obviously
we would all have that choice whether
it's in the primary with our own party
or in the general election it gives that
candidate time to get to know folks out
in the state um someone also asked when
would they be chosen um I liked what the
chair said but if that's a contention
for you I encourage you to look at that
but um you know ultimately this could be
um to quote a president I like you know
um our next Governor's uh first best
choice it's a great way to look at the
type of people that they would consider
uh working with it could give them an
opportunity to expand to maybe a place
that that gubernatorial candidate
doesn't have a natural strength in you
know whether it's a part of the state or
a different gender or older or younger I
just think that this what the way that
this resolution I think that's what we
call this not a bill um right resolution
resol yes uh you know I think the way
that it's written is just very much in
the in the sense of what of New
Hampshire I can imagine that the um
gubernatorial candidate would choose
someone who would already be traveling
in with and in support of him or her um
anyway uh and I can't really see a
downside to this um other than maybe
fixing a few things that you may
disagree with the resolution on if you
um like the questions
reflected um having said that I'm happy
to take any questions you may have but I
will you know I'm a Democrat I'm happy
to show that I am one of more quite a
few Democrats that also support this
effort thank you representative Schultz
are there any
questions no very good job it's great to
see you all thank you so much
representative
F thank you madam chair and members of
the committee uh I am Lily Foss I'm a
first-term democratic rep from
Manchester uh representing Awards 245
and 7 in the Hillsboro 41
floweral uh aside from being a new State
Rep I have a degree in politics with an
emphasis in legal studies from scripts
college and between that uh Temple
University School of Law and my uh
unfortunate habit of listening to
constitutional oral arguments just for
fun uh I have background in
constitutional law uh so when I have
looked at uh when representative Moffett
asked me to you know look at this
resolution and potentially speak on
it I read it I I asked him what he uh
you know what what's your advocacy and I
asked what are the arguments against and
from my understanding and again I am I
am a first term rep the uh a lot of the
arguments against were we haven't needed
it so far it's been years we haven't
needed it it hasn't come up and perhaps
it's just me being a first term Rip but
that argument just in general seems
rather strange to me because if you had
a structural flaw in a bridge you
wouldn't wait until the bridge collapse
to do anything about it you don't wait
until you're dead to buy life insurance
you if you see something that could
become a problem in the future you
change it and if we weren't in a
legislative context that would seem
irresponsible not
to
but you make the argument well we
haven't need it so far I mean
representative mfet gave some examples
where this has come up but I if you know
perhaps someone was inclined to think
that well that's relatively minor the
consequences you know potentially
weren't that impactful um as I said I
have a background in constitutional law
so I would like to draw the committee's
attention to the 12th Amendment of the
US Constitution and the election of 1796
so the election of 1800 gets a lot of uh
attention and an entire song in Hamilton
but the election of 1796 was actually
the only election where the president
and the vice president were of of
different parties uh John Adams that was
his one presidential term and then
Thomas Jefferson was the vice president
that's because the way the Constitution
was originally written uh an elector
seven states direct the popular vote
elected their electors and then in nine
states uh the state legislature elected
their electors the electors voted for
two people but they weren't on separate
presidential and vice presidential
tickets they couldn't vote for the same
person so the person who won the most
votes provided it was a majority of the
votes would become the president the
runnerup would become the vice president
so that and some interference by
Alexander Hamilton is how you ended up
with the Federalist Johan Adams as the
president and the uh Democratic
Republican Thomas Jefferson as the vice
president at first they were cordial but
at the very beginning uh Jefferson
stopped Consulting with Adams on any
political decisions
whatsoever so because of well not
because of but because of this Discord
focus on on on the on the point please
of course well this is an example this
Discord that arose from
having uh legislators or a vice
president and a president of two
different parties uh this is the same
kind of Discord that could result if we
were to have a uh a governor who perhaps
was of a different party than their
staff or the um members who had been
appointed by the other governor and
furthermore it's not who the voters of
New Hampshire would have voted for you
know say the president of the Senate who
became governor was a different party
than the governor that's not what the
voters of New Hampshire want wanted in
their gubernatorial candidate and to
speak again as the to the bipartisanship
you know I'm a Democrat if the president
of the Senate became uh Governor it
would not benefit my party any uh the
governor you know not of my party so
this is purely I'm I'm here because the
voters of New Hampshire deserve to have
a governor who represents who they voted
for uh and I
again I hope that uh not just the
historical examples but just thinking of
the potential consequences and what's uh
more reflective of the voters of New
Hampshire I I hope that the committee
will support this
resolution thank you very much are there
any
questions I don't see any so thank you
for your testimony thank you
okay I I checked off I'm opposed to this
bill and um I think probably in its
current Farm better not to send this to
the voters but I uh obviously I wouldn't
be here if I didn't think it was an
interesting idea so I
appreciate U so enjoyed listening to the
previous previous previous three reps
the bipartisan group of three reps so I
think certainly probably the proper
course of action is to retain the bill
because I think even the supporters
agree it might need some tweaking um I'm
not sure whether it's a good idea to
have pay just the lieutenant governor
just $125 a year since that's a somewhat
uh job of somewhat different nature than
being you know a senator even the Senate
President so that would probably become
a full-time job and there would also
there' be some significant cost because
this person would probably need a
security detail they would need probably
like they probably at least have some
staffers they probably couldn't just use
all the staffers from the uh governor's
office or from the Senate cuz this uh
individual would be the uh be the the
president it would also be the president
of the Senate so they' be essentially a
25th member of the Senate even though
they would vote only when there's a tie
which actually there are lots of ties in
the Senate because theyve even a number
of Senators so um probably some of their
budget could come out of the could come
out of the Senate but there would be a
significant cost and um so I just I
think probably I recognize you may need
to do some work on the line of
succession and this might be a vehicle
you could use to do that but I think um
probably probably be best either not
have a lieutenant governor or to
actually pay them you know have have
them set the salary during the budget
process which um and of course um the
budget process it'll be a while before
there be a budget process that could
deal with it because if if indeed you
pass this or some amended version of it
um it would would be voted on in
November
2026 um obviously the office would be
office would be vacant throughout 2027
and 20 2028 and also the next future
legislators leg legislature would have
to work on probably some enabling
legislation you know they need to flesh
out what the powers of this person is
what their duties are what
responsibilities we have to them so
there obviously there have to be some
compan Indian bills so be a you do have
a while to uh you've got like a whole
year before you even have to send any
decide what to send over to the other
body the body that
will body like who's President the um
who's President the lieutenant governor
would be at least in this version of the
bill so you know you've we've got a
while before we have to sort everything
out I will say I've only unlike R
Schultz I've only worked in one other
state house and that was in
Massachusetts and they have a lieutenant
governor if I recall correctly is
elected separately from the governor um
most of them been pretty pretty obscure
but uh John kery was recent the
legislative governor of of uh legisl
lieutenant governor of Massachusetts and
you've all heard of him there was uh
Jane Swift who became the uh youngest
Governor I think in at the time I think
in US history who was a well she was the
acting Governor so she was the
lieutenant governor when the governor
resigned um so
and and I think you in that case
actually they made the governor a member
of the governor's councils they have a
Governor's Council has much less power
than ours but they do have one so you
could also add you know you could have
that Governor be the chair of the
governor's Council or something or uh so
maybe there probably other other so
that's that's another possibility what
you could do with this person to keep
them busy while they're waiting around
for the governor to leave and certainly
and also you may want to flesh out what
the senten it says about what to do if
there's a vacancy in the off office of
government although that's probably not
a bad approach to have only have the
special election if the governor dies
resigns or otherwise leaves uh before um
before the first first term of his her
term is up but that's probably something
else you could appropriately appropriate
look at while you're dealing with this
cacr so I would certainly um so I
certainly would uh I certainly wouldn't
be able to I certainly would not be one
of the 240 votes if this came if this
was sent to the floor um as is but I
think there's probably a pretty good
chance you're going to work on it
because it's kind of an interesting idea
so I would uh so I certainly urge you to
at least um come up with something you
know it's a there may be I think there's
like some interesting ideas you may want
to make it even more interesting before
you send it over here and so um right
now I would not be one of the 240 people
you would need to passed us on to the
Senate and then to the voters so so I'd
be happy to take any questions thank you
representative forgan are there any
questions no all right thank does anyone
else wish to testify on
ccr1 okay seeing none I will close the
public hearing and open the hearing on
House Bill 470 with an apology to the
sponsors and testifiers we've it's been
Cal I am sorry these we had two bills
that took a great deal more time than we
thought they would I apologize uh no
problem actually I was downstairs in
executive session so the timing worked
out so thank you convenient
um so thank you uh thank you madam
chairwoman and members of the committee
uh for the record my name is Jim kofalt
I represent Hillsburg County District 32
which is the towns of Wilton Temple and
new IP
switch H Bill 470 is intended to address
some serious concerns about access to
care patient safety and health care
costs these concerns were brought to my
attention last year when the New
Hampshire Board of dental examiners
proposed rule changes to Jael car aimed
at restricting qualified Dental
professionals from administering
sedation and anesthesia under certain
circumstances these changes would have
significant negative consequences for
the people of New
Hampshire and uh would have put New
Hampshire dramatically out of sync with
nationally accepted standards for
Dentistry we it would they would have
made the only state in the country to
impose these kinds of unnecessary
restrictions fortunately uh the proposed
rule changes were not adopted um when
they were brought before gel car I
believe that the Dental Board of
examiners has uh circled back to make
some revisions that would probably be in
line as I understand are probably going
to be in line with the bill before you
um having said that I still think the
bill is important so that we can assure
be assured that we have uh a clear
statement of legislative intent as to
what is appropriate and what is not
appropriate under the
circumstances so what this bill would do
is it would affirmatively supersede
those proposed changes by preserving the
scope of practice that has always uh
been applied in New Hampshire and
assuring that it continues to align with
nationally recognized standards for
Dentistry um so just by way background
um dentists use moderate sedation deep
sedation and general aesthesia to calm
patients with anxiety and to comfortably
treat patients who are undergoing
painful
procedures when a general or uh
pediatric dentist determines that a
patient's condition requires additional
expertise or additional equipment they
make may make a referral to a uh
maxilofacial surgery office um so an
oral
surgeon an oral and Max maxilofacial
surgeon or om um generally under goes
four to 6 years of residency training uh
in a hospital based setting uh that is
generally uh you know followed by
Decades of experience on average um so
these are people who are highly highly
qualified to treat patients in their
offices with
sedation the proposed rule brought
brought by the Dental Board uh was was
Den 304 and that would have mandated the
presence of a separate anesthesia
provider um for patients under 9 years
of
age uh in that case um the the MS the
the surgeon in question would have to
wait for an anesthesia provider uh
either either do that or attempt to
transfer the patient to a hospital or
would have to refer them to the
emergency room uh it's also worth noting
that we have a shortage of anesthesia
providers in New Hampshire and Hospital
capacity is is restricted in many places
at many times
so the you know why would they want to
do this well the impetus for this
proposed change arose um as a result of
the death of a child in California some
years ago after a thorough
investigation um the the state of
California determined that in that case
it was the practitioner who was at fault
not the system of
delivery um and
so some people have used this as a as a
as a basis for one to restrict scope of
of practice for for these oral
surgeons um currently Dental
Professionals in New Hampshire follow
very strict guidelines for informed
consent uh they can work with parents
and Guardians to make sure that they are
uh fully informed of the the benefits
and the risks of
sedation the risks of of moderate
sedation the risk of sedation in general
are extraordinarily low um the informed
consent process generally involves also
informing patients of what the
alternatives are and what the risks are
associated with those Alternatives
because um there there are often risks
associated with with any given
alternative um
so in my view it is the uh the
individual Dental professionals and
their patients who who should be working
together to determine uh the best course
of action and the best procedures that
they want to follow
to assure adequate patient care um
working with parents and Guardians uh in
the case of of children under
N9 so that current model really affords
us a safe and cost-effective means of
delivering these
services and I don't believe that that
should change and I've spoken to many
Dental professionals who do not believe
that that should change we have never
seen an incident in New Hampshire that
would justify this level of massive
change to the system so there are
significant negative consequences that
would arise from such a
change uh first it would increase the
cost of care so um if you can imagine
that you're required to bring on an
anesthesia professional professional for
certain uh
procedures um it also would potentially
require that certain procedures be
performed in a hospital setting it would
create new limits on access to care as
well so without access to office-based
options uh many patients in New
Hampshire would have to um wait long
they would have longer wait times for
treatment
potentially um and presumably they would
have additional costs associated with
hospital care if that is where they get
their services uh as a result of it of
such a
change this would also preclude Medicaid
patients from getting treatment
requiring moderate sedation so it it has
an effect on people um without the means
to um fund these things or without
private
insurance um in many cases this rule
would have the effect of of essentially
forcing certain procedures to happen in
a hospital setting adding further cost
and also requiring patients who may
already have significant anxiety to be
treated in a very clinical environment
whereas dental offices tend to be um
relatively calming places that may be
familiar
um you know for me you know I it it also
occurred to me that this could have an
especially negative impact on people
with developmental disabilities so some
of you I think are aware that I have a a
particular Keen interest in um advancing
uh advancing the interests of of people
with Autism and families of people with
Autism and um there is a there is
discomfort associated with things like
going to the dentist or undergoing um
oral Sur surgery um that level of
discomfort and anxiety as you can
imagine is Amplified considerably if
somebody is taken to an unfamiliar
setting with unfamiliar people in a in a
more clinical environment so that could
be overwhelming I think to a lot of
people with developmental disabilities
um
so well I understand that those proposed
changes are not at this point slated to
go into effect and that the Dental Board
is working to address the concerns that
were raised in the in the Jael car
process um I do believe that this bill
should still move forward at this point
um I think that it's important for the
legislature to assert um its intention
and um assure that any rule changes that
go forward do not unnecessarily restrict
scope of practice increase cost of care
and decrease patient access that ends my
testimony and I'm open to questions
okay representative Sellers and then
Schmidt thank you madam chair
representative um so the intent here is
to allow your typical dentist to give
more sedation or a stronger U um what do
I want to say painkiller if you want to
say to like pull a tooth or something
like that uh thank you for the question
so it's the purpose of this legislation
is to allow Dental professionals to
continue what they've been doing for
many many many years and that they have
been trained to do and um have undergone
Hospital residency training to do um it
applies primarily to um OMS oral
um sorry I don't have it in front of me
thank you um we'll accept oral surgeons
oral surgeons yes so so I would I would
defer to some of the people who are
probably going to be speaking after me
to give further details but but I would
stress that really when when I filed
this legislation
those rules were still under the old
rules were still under
consideration um I would still like to
see it move forward because I think we
we need to be clear about legislative
intent having said that um the the the
primary answer to your question is this
bill would allow them to do what they
have always done they have always done
safely in New Hampshire we've never had
any negative incidents um surrounding
this issue and um it would align New
Hampshire or have New Hampshire continue
to align with nationally recognized
standards representative
Schmid thank you madam
chair so um did I understand you
correctly to say that were we to go
forward with this legislation we would
be the only state to do to have such
legislation in the United States was was
that your testimony thank you for the
question no it was not it was actually
the opposite if the rules this this
legislation is intended to um to prevent
any rules such as the ones that were
proposed from going into effect so by
passing this legislation well let me
back up if those rules had gone into
effect we would have been the only state
to have such restrictions on scope of
practice by passing this legislation we
would be guaranteeing that we are
continuing to align with nationally
recognized standards that every other
state is is practicing thank you okay
other questions representative sers I'm
sorry I should have asked you for follow
no that's okay thank you madam chair so
so right now they can they can use the
anesthetic that's necessary that's what
you're saying correct they they can all
right thank you any other
questions all right thank you very much
excuse me representative citech you
you uh you said that and then you talked
at length about a lot of things uh that
Happ which are all all all right
now um isn't that true I mean it went
through quite a bit it sounded like
these were prohibited or you have to do
this go to the oral surgeon probably
does flag work too
Vex um that's all that's all moot right
now no the the rule rules are still have
are still being developed and we don't
know what exactly the board of dental
examiners will present they are still We
There was an objection and they are
going going back to work on them we do
not know what would come up prophylactic
yes thank thank you so so my answer to
the question um I appreciate um the
chairwoman's uh comments yes it's the
the objective of the legislation at this
point is to serve as a back stop and
make sure that we protect patient safety
access to care and um reasonable costs
okay thank
you all right thank you uh Tommy Burke
excuse me representative Leon wishes to
thank you madam chair uh members of the
committee for the record Erica Lon
representing the town of dairy um as a
co-sponsor of this bill I wanted to come
up here into this more appropriate space
to speak um on the reasons and necessity
for this bill um previously in past
years there was a bill that was adopted
that was rather reactionary to that
circumstance of that child that died in
California some of the language that was
passed was interpreted in such a way by
the board of medicine while trying to
implement these um implement the new
rules that allowed for it to be much
more restrictive than anywhere else in
the country the language of the law has
the May statement that is in there that
then that is crossed out because it
provided for the ability to exempt um
oral maxio facial surgeons to continue
practicing the way that they've always
been trained to do and to continue on
with their high level of training to
provide this anesthesia and these and
this sort of um pain control and comfort
care the way that it was interpreted was
ambiguous as to the legislative intent
so this bill was filed to make it clear
that we're not looking to have make our
oral surgeons operate in a an
environment that's more restrictive than
anywhere else in the country we are want
to make sure that patients are safe
which is why this references the um
National standards we want also want to
make sure that this is done in a way
that isn't going to preclude New
Hampshire children from getting this
care because there is not just a risk of
um anesthesia there's also a risk from
not being treated so if a patient has a
be a abscess they have an infected tooth
and they're not able to get treatment in
the right time they people have died
from that and we don't want children who
are not able to be treated because they
can't find a nurse and esus to come in
or there's not Hospital space the
treatment is is delayed and then that
infection then takes that child's life
so this is a bill to make to make clear
that it that the with the training and
with those standards these oral surgeons
are able to continue doing what they've
done we need this this change in law
would be very helpful to ensure that the
rules that are in process and are
hopefully going to be um drafted in a
way that's consistent with this that
they move forward and then in the future
the same concern over legislative intent
doesn't come up on Rural renewal and
then put us right back in this position
where we may be denying access to care
for
children okay are there any questions
repres pitech you met of examiners you
meant Board of dental examiners didn't
you said Board of Medicine who who has
jurisdiction over this it's been a long
day for all of us I think it's Dental
examiners okay all right just the
appropriate
board okay anyone else have a question
all right thank you representative thank
good afternoon thank you all uh for for
uh being here um my name is Tommy Burke
I'm an oral Maxell facial surgeon
practicing in Nashua and Bedford New
Hampshire I'm currently serving as the
president of the uh New Hampshire
Society of Orland Maxwell facial
surgeons in that role I represent the 52
surgeons in our state who strive to um
achieve safe and affordable access to
care for our our patients um I'm also
joined by two of my colleagues drors
bean and Malik who will also plan to
provide testimony um about um their um
experience as well as our anesthesia
safety um track record as well as our
concerns for access to care um I'm
really grateful for the opportunity to
speak with you all today about HP 470
which I urge you to support um the Crux
of this is that we are looking to
establish and strengthen the dental
practice act um so that oral surgeons or
ms's whatever you want to call us um can
uh provide sedation but also comply with
anesthesia um regulations that are in
line with national standards um we are
as was outlined by by representative
kofalt um we're extensively trained we
spend 8 to 10 years in training after
college um throughout Dental SCH School
Medical School residency training to be
able to do procedures as well as
administer anesthesia to our patients
it's not something that we take lightly
and something that we take very
seriously um like many of my colleagues
in the state um I obtained my medical
degree as well as my dental degree on
the path to becoming an oral surgeon so
you may ask why is this bill necessary
so the bill is necessary um due to the
previous proposal by the Dental Board um
of den 304 um which moved to make the
anesthesia outpatient anesthesia model
that we use um to be more restrictive
and prohibitive and we had concerns
regarding the changes that were proposed
because um this could potentially
restrict um access to care for patients
and also restrict our ability um and um
how we administer anesthesia in our
offices um to give you context in
dentistry there are different
organizations the national standards of
care for training are provided by the
commission on Dental accreditation or
Koda now with regards to parameters of
care and what you can do that is
dictated by individual specialty
organizations my organization the
American associ Association of oral and
maxal facial surgeons um there's also
the American Dental Association American
Academy for Pediatric Dentistry Etc um
there has been collaboration a lot of
different Dental Specialties actually
administer anesthesia and there's been
collaboration amongst the different
Dental Specialties um in particular the
uh American Academy of Ms um the dental
anesthesia committee um as well as
periodontology um collaborated and
issued joint um joint guidelines that
provide a framework for individual
states to write legislation um that uh
for these for these contacts and this
was this um these guidelines were
drafted after um significant uh
collaboration and deliberation um and
Reconciliation amongst the issues
amongst these different Specialties
which is not an easy task um the
concerns and I think those have been
well outlined about what was proposed
with Den
304 and we proposed um or we advocated
about this at jail car um was that
the the changes that would be proposed
with that with Den 304 would be that
time sensitive emergency treatment um
particularly for Pediatric patients
wouldn't be possible in many offices in
particular with deep sedation because
what would be mandated is that we would
be required to have a second anesthesia
provider present which is not something
that's typically done on an on call
basis that can be done on a same day
basis um so the concerns in those
emergency scenarios is these patients
would then need to present to the
emergency room be admitted to the
hospital and then this ends up being a
greater um cost to the patients as well
as um to the greater Health Care System
um as well and it's not just oral
surgeons by the way um it's not
something that we we were just you know
we are all trained to do this but in
addition pediatric dentists for example
are trained to do moderate sedation and
as those rules were written and uh with
the original version of den
304 um those uh no pediatric dentist
would be able to administer moderate
sedation in the state as they were
written now jail car did move the uh
rules back to the Dental Board and they
have been um working hard to revise
those we commend them for the revisions
that have been made and feel like they
have made some positive steps however um
we believe that the changes in HB 470
are still necessary to help improve the
dental practice act as those changes are
still pending as of this hearing um as
was outlined there's no other state in
the country that has these um the
regulations in Den 304 um in states that
actually had adverse outcomes such as in
California North Carolina and Texas
there were analyses of these um of these
these cases and looked at a larger data
set and they ultimately decided to not
adopt such a restrictive position so in
in short you know the state of New
Hampshire as well as um doctors doctors
like like myself um sh responsibility to
provide patient safety and access to
care we need this language in law for
the board of dental examiners to write
rules that are in line with national
standards of
Care thank you thank you are there any
questions representative scitec and then
Schmidt um Dr Burke I got president and
I got Mex facial but I didn't get all in
between there's quite a mouthful there
so to speak who so to speak what what's
your title president of what I'm
president of the New Hampshire Society
of oral and Maxell facial surgeons nhss
is probably the easiest way to write it
oral
and
surgeons okay okay thank you
representative Schmidt thank you madam
chair okay so as a member of the Jael
car I believe you were not there the day
that we wrestled with this at the jelar
but you and I spoke subsequently so the
language that we're looking at is
language which you and your legal
Associates have have um perfected shall
we
say yes the goal of this is to Bas
basically not make things more
restrictive as they currently are and I
think that was there was some
questioning earlier it seemed that you
know well it it's you know we're it's a
um problem in search of a or a solution
in sear problem in search of a solution
I should say so follow up okay follow up
so and what I'm concerned about is
getting uh lawmaking in between uh a
doctor and his patient in a way and I'm
concerned that if the language is not
perfect uh that it may lead to uh a
tieup uh that would not be in the
interest of either either the doctors or
their patients because as I understand
it these circumstances are somewhat
unusual because they involve um children
sometimes very small children who are uh
have been injured in some face in some
way like a been struck by a baseball bat
or a car accident or whatever where you
have a very small patient that has a big
problem uh and they need emergency
surgery to save their life um so what
I'm concerned about is whether the
language could potentially get in the
way of something that as long as these
Dental rules are not uh you know in
place and they are not before the jel
car yet uh uh you can proceed as as
representative kall testified you can
proceed to to practice best practice
medicine uh dentistry in this case
uh you know as needed by the patient uh
and under the circumstances that you are
best qualified to dictate in other words
this would have to go into a hospital
with all of facilities that you might
not have um in your practice so you
could do it right now the the rules are
not likely to get approved unless they
are um
also not going to prevent you from doing
what you need to do and what you
currently can do uh so uh are you
satisfied that the language that is
before us right
now cannot possibly be misinterpreted to
prevent you from being able to do what
you currently can do with the with the
verbiage that's in there we we tried to
make it so that it was in line with
national standards so as far as it's
written right now that would not
restrict our ability to do um what we
what we doing currently okay well that's
very important thank you other
questions
speeches all right thank you doctor
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee um my name is Salon Malik I'm
an oral surgeon uh I've been in private
practice in New Hampshire for uh since
1997 uh like Dr Burke I'm licensed both
in Dentistry and Medicine I'm board
certified in oral Maxwell facial surgery
and uh in Dental anesthesia by the
American Dental Society of
anesthesiology just to give you an idea
in general uh I average about 400
anesthesia cases a year in my practice
which is probably the the standard the
the typical pace for an neural surgeon
in private practice um and uh like most
surgeons it's a single uh practitioner
model so I deliver the anesthesia and I
do the surgery and as an oral surgeon
usually I say you know the buck stops
here in in dentistry itself when
things get to the point where they need
to be done and it can be done usually
the oral surgeon ends up treating those
kind of cases so this is where access to
care and patient safety and uh health
care costs become important because of
the kind of rules and regulations we
have to deal with in order to provide
that
care um I think we can all agree that
patient safety is the most important
issue here and patient safety is not
just a one one single term that we need
to look at uh as has been discussed
before uh the cost and access to care
they're all intertwined if a p if a
patient whether it's an adult or a child
can't have the kind of uh care that he
or she needs at the moment now we're
looking at issues that may be difficult
to resolve and we get to a point of
trying to decide what to do so I'm in
full support of this bill um I would say
say that uh all you have to do is really
look at sort of like an example so if if
there's a patient and usually it's a
child uh who needs uh an emergency
dental care and it's really medicine
it's dental medicine it's all the same
um the patient ends up in my office I
have to make a decision the decision
will always come in first without money
involved what does the child need and if
it's an emergency it has to be treated
and timing is important but it's biology
we're not talking about in the moment it
could be within an hour it could be a
day it could be a week and that's the
position I'm in to make that decision if
something is going to be done within the
next couple of hours which is what I
have to do I have to make a decision can
I do it in the office if there are so
many restrictions where I have to get as
was mentioned before another
anesthesiologist or an
anesthetist I probably won't be able to
do the case and the child probably won't
get that care that day I would then have
to make a decision okay I can take them
to the hospital because I have
privileges to take patients to the
hospital I can do it in the O well since
covid it's not that easy to take a child
or any patient to the O all right so
let's say I do get that time and
probably it's not going to be that day
and in residency training we always
heard you know never let sunset or
sunrise or sunset on an absess so if I'm
going to have that child not treated
that day I'm going to have to wait
another day now patient safety is
another issue whether the child needs to
be admitted or not when I do take that
patient to the O ever since covid the
quality of care in the O is different
it's not the same as it used to be in my
office I have three surgical assistants
they're all pediatric Advanced life
cardiac they're all um trained with
certifications they're all dance
certified which is another certification
where they learn how to administer as an
assistant anesthesia with the surgeon
but if they go to the O I have a crew
that doesn't know me as well I don't
know them I have equipment that I've not
worked with on a daily basis so that's
another compromise now that's assuming
we can take the child to the O that day
if I can't take the patient to the O in
that hospital now I have to start
thinking about referring that patient
and the only referral I can make from my
practice
uh is usually going to be someplace in
Boston and that's not very cost
effective and again time becomes an
issue
and from a practical point of view then
I'd have to have that conversation with
the parents and say I know the
anesthesia would have been couple $100
in an office setting now you're going to
go to the hospital presumably either
locally or in in uh outside of the state
and it's going to be in the thousands of
dollars and it's all because of
restrictions that were that were thought
of at one point or another yes the board
of dental
examiners uh is revisiting the
restrictions that they were thinking
about putting in uh but I think with
this bill in place we'll have a Model A
a standardized model that we can at
least look to and then use now it's
still not going to be black and white I
heard about
language when you deal with medicine
when you deal with surgery when you deal
with Biology it can't be black and white
I'm sure there'll be some things that we
may need to
change uh what they are I can't tell you
because I look at the patient I I don't
look at the words but those words are
going to help us at least form a
template to do what we need to do and
which what we've been doing for for
decades in the state of New Hampshire um
I'll stop my comments here so if there
are any questions thank you
representative Schmidt has a
question so I I've given a lot of
thought to this doctor every since I
talked with Dr Burks I serve on the Jael
car you I don't believe you were there
the day that we heard this and and
objected to the proposed rules from the
Bode okay uh and there was there were a
number of uh of oral surgeons there who
were begging us basically please do not
accept these rules because they will
potentially uh you know potentially
affect the life survival of of a small
child um so so I've given a lot of
thought uh to it and talk with Dr Burks
and so forth um but and you have
reviewed this language because I'd
rather stay out of it not
have legislation getting in between the
doctors and their and their patients
okay so I'd rather not do nothing and
let you continue to do what you
currently can do thank you then have
Lang language which uh still has to go
through the Senate even if we adopt it
here uh and it passes the house which
I'm sure it would uh it's going to have
to go to the Senate so we're talking
about
months uh before it would be ready for
the Governor's
signature uh
and I'm wondering whether you have
reviewed this language yourself and
you're as comfortable with it as Dr
Burke do well I reviewed the language
but I can honestly tell you I can't say
I'm comfortable because I'm not that
knowledgeable
about the language is the only way I can
put it I mean I agree with what's
written in there and if there are going
to be
some issues that need to be resolved
it's not something I can I feel I'm an
expert at to to say yes there are some
changes that need to be made okay thank
you and thank you we understand the
intent okay represent scitech you have a
question you said you did 400 of these a
year you do two a day yes wow well two a
day or three three or four a day because
know we we thank you for your service
Bean I'm uh Jonathan Bean I'm a
practicing a board certified or maxal
surgeon out of Manchester and Penbrook
um I wanted to first thank uh
representative Kofa and representative
Lyon for uh uh their testimony that is
uh I think they summarized a lot of
things that I was going to touch on as
did Dr Bert and Dr Malik um so I'll try
to keep uh my information um my
testimony
brief um
I've practiced in U Manchester and
Penbrook here for a total of about five
or so years I've also practiced in North
Conway location our uh Nash and Salem
locations as well as our Danver
Massachusetts location um so I've had
some experience in different areas in
state of New Hampshire even New England
I've practiced in other states such as
Colorado South Carolina and Kentucky um
so I have a perspective on outside
philosophies and modalities even with my
own profession um I currently hold
privileges at Elliot Hospital and
Catholic Medical Center uh the HB 470 in
my mind is uh designed to uh serve the
people of New Hampshire and preserving
their access to our services as well as
the services of the pediatric
dentist um the rule changes that were
proposed before they you know as
everybody's already said at this point
were very restricted
and would have had they gone through
made us the most restrictive State
that's a uh true statement and that the
the other problem is you had no viable
alternative for their care like even the
board at that meeting recommended that
uh if they were not able to gain access
to our clinic for care because of these
restrictions that they should just go to
the hospital and they'll deal with it
that was that was literally the
testimony that the board of dentistry
gave I can't begin to explain how wrong
that is uh that being said obviously the
things have kind of pulled back and Jae
car sent it back to them I agree but you
had asked about the language of this and
I I mean I I would in part agree with Dr
Malik I'm not the expert but I would
agree that it does state that hey we're
supposed to follow these National
guidelines National guidelines are
fairly specific in how they lay out what
our rules rules are now what happens
that the
Senate they make a change now is that
does that change things here yeah I
don't know I can't control that but what
I would say is I do support this bill as
it is written and um how is and I do
think the way it is written uh leaves
room for practitioners to make decisions
here on their own preserve their
autonomy with uh pediatric patient
population and the rest of the demog
Graphics in New
Hampshire um in a way that that that
serves this
state uh you know we are well trained um
you know they mentioned the you know
time Beyond College uh we we do four to
six years of residency depending on your
program um the there is a five month
minimum on anesthesia service in which
you are the primary anesthesia provider
in an operating room so you mentioned
teeth yeah we do that in our clinic but
you know
in our training if you're coming in for
your appendix you might get us as your
anesthesia
provider um you know so that that we do
for five months in addition to that
there's a minimum requirement of at
least one month dedicated to Pediatric
anesthesia uh so specific to that
population and if even with those
requirements we're still required to
have 30 months on our own service and
which we routinely give uh deep sedation
general anesthesia and our outpatients
clinics uh to any number of patients
across all
demographics uh throughout that whole
time in the
same uh modality that we do it in
private practice so we are literally
trained to do both of these things uh
the rule changes one of the main
concerns with d 304 is that it presented
this Avenue that all of a sudden the
board could come forward and just cut
off this access and make this drastic
change uh a number of which those
recommendations were made by people that
have uh no background in anesthesia and
so it it really created a lot of issues
this bill the reason why we support uh
House Bill 470 is that it uh kind of
protects that practice and that service
that we provide by saying hey you just
got to follow National guidelines and uh
you know it serves the the data that
backs up those guidelines as a opposed
to being out on your own potentially and
having to explain that
so okay but that's uh I thank you for
questions excellent thank you thank you
Lori
thank you for the record I'm Lori Rosado
I reside here in conquer and I'm a
practicing general dentist here in
conquer uh thank you representatives for
allowing me to speak a lot of what I had
to say has already been spoken and so I
don't want to repeat the process it's in
my testimony so what I will do instead
is talk to you about from my perspective
as a general
dentist as a general dentist I'll give
you an example child comes in in the
morning mother calls my child child is
swollen infected they get into my chair
I evaluate the child usually a child
like that is crying in pain needs to be
sedated as a general dentist we don't do
that we refer to an oral surgeon at that
point my team calls the oral surgery
practice we have several in the state
that are excellent here in Conger we
have several we call the oral surgeons
practice tell them it's an emergency
situation we can't leave the child
swollen like this
they will accommodate us they'll get the
child into their chair within a few
hours so if you picture the time frame
I'm assessing in the morning they get to
the oral surgeon hopefully by early
afternoon the oral surgeon assesses them
and makes a decision can I sedate this
child or there's the someone that I
would have to bring to the O in the
cases where they can Sate which are many
they can safely sedate a child right now
take care of the infection either
provide IV antibiotics we're given the
antibiotics they need to go home with
and the child is safely treated and the
situation is
done if this bill doesn't pass or if the
rules change happen that oral surgeon
has to find o time at 3 o'clock in the
afternoon or in the that time frame and
now we look at can that child be treated
today if the child can't be treated that
day they have to be admitted to the
hospital extra costs IV antibiotics and
in the hospital extra costs wait for o
time extra costs all
unnecessary we know these children can
be safely treated here we've been doing
it for decades so I as a proponent of
the bill speaking from the general
dentist Community I ask that you guys
questions apparently not thank you very
director
jurus good afternoon just for the record
de jurus executive director oplc and uh
with me just in case for
questions Nicholas fry general
counsel the oplc is not taking a
position on this bill we're just
available if the committee has any
questions uh no testimony from
us thank you I I think that the the only
possible implication might be that the
board of dental examiners might need to
look at their rules again if it were to
pass is that
correct I would agree with that
assessment yes okay any questions all
right seeing none thank you for uh for
waiting
okay would rules be necessary the rules
would rules are always
necessary is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on House Bill
470 all right seeing on I will close the
public
hearing
what yeah it's 4:00 so yeah let's do
this one at
least see with those all right I think
the committee will go into executive
SL ah well that case let's uh we'll
definitely quit before
five Indian one most of the questions
were people on the Pion subcommittee so
if we would have send it to my
subcomittee we were the I would have to
like now okay um should I can you wait
two minutes five minutes I think this
one's going to be
easy
okay
um since we have people that will that
have longer commutes than many of us
only this spill I think we will only do
this spill I just fake does someone have
a moot have a motion Madame chair I move
a to pass on H Bill 470 I'll second okay
move by representative groa second by
representative Lon
uh do you wish to speak to your
motion
yes I do I'm very concerned that any T
any changes in the rules that would make
access stricter and reduce accessibility
to treatment for anyone who needs um
oral surgery is a concern to us and I
would um hope that the committee would
have been motivated by the testimony
that they've heard
today thank you representable Anne um
thank you madam chair I I believe that
this is critical to make sure that we
can protect access and protect the
health of our youngest residents and so
I urge the committee to support this any
other comments questions
issues
wow yes okay okay in that case the
motion is ought to pass on House Bill
Vice chairman L
yes the clerk votes
yes uh representative Pearson
yes representative Bailey
I representative shien
I
yes um two four 6 8 10 124 I guess we
have two
absent okay the motion passes can I move
consent on
that yeah I was just about to ask but
yes is there any objection to
consent all right seeing none repr
representative movers and seconders
again please move by representative grus
second by representative
Leon and we will put this on consent
since nobody seems to object thank you
all for surviving today we will be
meeting next Wednesday on almost
left
uh thank you
John you're welcome what I didn't do
anything but you're welcome 32 bills eth
here
hello